e
good
good morning everyone and welcome to the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and El Affairs we have a couple
of hearings on non- gerain amendments
this morning and then we'll have an
executive session later on uh but before
we get into any of that I'd ask you to
Allegiance pledge allegiance to the flag
of the United States of America and to
the Republic for it one nation un God
everyone okay the
first um Amendment we'll be taking up
this morning is on um it's Amendment 17
uh 2024 hyen 1725 H to Senate Bill 458
and I would
recognize representative Gary Merchant
the sponsor good morning representative
Merchant thank you Mr chairman also
thank you uh to the good morning to the
committee uh for the record my name is
Gary Merchant a representative from
District Six in Sullivan County
representing clamont and
Cen I bring before the committee for
their consideration an amendment to
house so Senate Bill
458 we're trying to amend in the chapter
318 which deals with pharmacies and
pharmacist the ability to work with a
license
for what I call a mini Pharmacy with
allowing clinics like Hamp oncology and
oncology to have a small Pharmacy within
the confines of the clinic for the
patient
populations what I found in trying to
31847 most of it had to be modified in
31837 and by moving it to a different
section of the RSA it was considered to
be n gerain so why move it from 47 to 37
is fundamentally what caused some of
confusion in the RSA as is written today
if you look at line nine on the
amendment you'll see it says here for
the sale at retail of drugs in medicines
even though the board felt they had the
authority to issue a license to a clinic
pharmacy if there was concerned that the
word retail which is really general
public was causing confusion so by
eliminating the
phrase at retail it minimizes that
reference um it does allow for the board
at that point in time to issue a permit
that doesn't have to be open to the
public so at that point in time you
could have it for a Nuclear Pharmacy
which they could do today you could have
for a Clinic Pharmacy you could have for
a Hospital Pharmacy the boards found
creative ways to minimize the impact of
the word retail which is basically
Community Pharmacy but by eliminating
this out of the statute today it does
allow the boort greater latitude and
flexibility to address the different
growing needs of War Pharmacy being
practice and with that I'll take
questions thank you any questions for
Weber so am I correct to understand that
the board has rules
under that that apply to the various
sorts of pharmacies yes okay correct so
this would simply allow them to make
rules for different
situations and continue their
appropriate oversight cor right thank
you representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
Merchant for working so hard on this um
my question is that we're sort of
looking at this mini Pharmacy idea and
my concern with this language is that
may be seen as a more one-sized fits-all
Pharmacy that may have may assume needs
that these in provider office pharmacies
um wouldn't actually have and then
therefore have requirements that aren't
appropriate to the situation does the
pharmacy board currently have different
sets of rules for different types of
pharmacies yes we yes we do okay we have
rules for
yeah actually as a followup do you mind
mentioning just a couple of the
different types we have rules for
Community Pharmacy and you can have an
ACC Community Pharmacy you can license
the whole store you can license only the
prescription Department you can also
have what they call Central field
Pharmacy which is not open to the public
today which only processes prescriptions
that are centralized and in send them to
the retail pharmacy for distribution to
the patients you have a Nuclear Pharmacy
you have um Long-Term Care Pharmacy you
have home Infusion pharmacy that's why
the board felt they probably could use
what they have today in statute to issue
a license for this location but by
removing the word retail it opens up or
minimizes if you will the some of the
barriers that were there in the
past
kman thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for uh bringing the amendment and taking
my question representative um we had
discussed uh that I I had some concerns
about um Physicians having full
pharmacies um in their practices simply
because there used to be um this kind of
whining and dining of Physicians where
the pharmaceutical companies would give
them samples and would incentivize them
to prescribe certain medications and I
think this um might be opening the door
for um some unethical practices and I
know that most doctors wouldn't do that
but um it has occurred in the past and
um I was hoping that there would be some
language in here about um disclosing to
the patient if if they have any
financial interest in prescribing
medication um and dispensing it to them
I don't see anything about that what can
you say no there's nothing in there for
that um I though I think we could put
something through to amend the non-
gerain amendment going down the road I
think one of the things also I heard was
the question of for patients for which
you're trying to get to maybe conflict
of interest is being sure the patient
understands they have the freedom of
choice they don't have to go to that
Pharmacy if it's in side of the clinic
they should be informed at that point in
time that they have always reserved the
right to go to any pharmacy they want to
it's their of their right if you will to
take their prescription and take it
wherever they want to if it's convenient
for them and it makes sense for them
they want to do it there b means it's
disclosed to them that's their choice
and their option but I think to your
point representative Coachman is the
fact that they should be clear they have
that
option other questions representative
Weber as a followup to that would it
be true that because of this
amendment the um medications are under
the pharmacy board rather than the
medical side of things and therefore
that prevent that that provides some
insulation and some oversight
specifically R relating to the dispens
ing side of things which would just in
and of itself provide a certain barrier
there it does provide a barrier the
Board of Pharmacy we have um in our
rules ethic guidelines and one of the
ethic guidelines is a Prohibition on
splitting the fee or splitting any
revenue between the pharmacist and the
position thank
you other questions representative Lon
um thank you Mr chairman and thanks for
taking another question representative
Merchant um I I know that you're aware
of RSA 415 colon 6-t which is the oral
anti-cancer therapies is the parity law
for insurance premiums uh my question
would be since I don't want to craft the
actual law that stays in statute to be
too specific to any one um need but um
I'm wondering if you would be open to
having um some legislative intent that's
in here that does go into the session
law stating that the reason for this
Bill coming specifically was to allow
you know basically in practice parody
with oral cancer medication with the
injectable the infusion-based um Can
anti-cancer medications and we
recognized that there may be broader
scope in applications so we didn't want
us to restrict the language but we
wanted to enable this with um
streamlined regulation in order to do
this is that something that you'd be
willing to look and help work with me on
be willing to discuss it with you repr
Leon I think right now with the parody
that's true no matter what pharmacy they
go to so that will hold in that section
with 406 that parody applies to all um
dispensing functionality now I think
when I need to go back and look at the
RSA specifically if it only deals a
parody with infused drugs versus
prescribed drugs for dispensing all
medications if you will so does does
statute say clearly it's oral
medications as well as infused that I
don't know as a followup follow um
with a followup um I I can check that
and see but my my intention was that
since we're looking at prescribing
parity um that to have a note that I
know this one is about the insurance
coverage but the intent the point is
that the infusible anti-cancer
medications have their own risks as well
and the transfer to the at home with the
oral cancer medicines that we need to
look at the fact that these doctors are
already doing it an office I I think
that would take a different um amend
that statute thing to amend it try to
amend it here number one it gets into
Commerce it gets into insurance policy
which is not what we're talking about
here today with this amendment
sorry representative
Weber would you agree with me
representative Merchant that when we put
something into chapter law it gets
buried and if we write a report for the
house which is the record of the house
and which is also a record of our intent
as the
legislature uh that is is far more
available to people and we could state
in our committee report our intent and
thereby preserve it clearly without
having to put it into statute or re
amend things that be restive um we
that's definitely one way to attack it
to address it thank you other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you
also signed up to speak is Dr Peter Crow
hematology Mr chairman if it's okay I'm
gonna come up with him I'm the other pin
card thank okay I wasn't sure how you
wanted to do that that's so also also
accompanying Dr is Gina
poers uh good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Dr Peter Crow and I'm an
oncology hematology specialist at New
Hampshire oncology hematology I appear
before you today with no position on the
amendment presented by representative
Merchant on SB
458 however there are a few issues that
I'd like to raise with the proposed
language as I stated just a few short
weeks ago when uh we asked Senator avar
to file this legislation as a result of
New Hampshire Board of Pharmacy's de uh
declaratory ruling that found that our
request to dispense non-controlled
prescription drugs in order to meet
patients immediate medical needs was
outside the board's
jurisdiction new have tonology was
simply seeking statutory Clarity move
before moving forward with any plans to
dispense oral anti-cancer medications we
heard the concerns of other stakeholders
after the initial public Hearing in the
Senate and attempted to develop language
that would allow us to dispense a 30day
supply of or oral anti-cancer
medications consistent with the regular
course of treat
uh that also put appropriately guard
appropriate guard rails in place in
statute and directing the Board of
Pharmacy to promate rules for this type
of practice we believe that this
targeted approach was appropriate so
it's not to disrupt or or open the
entire permitting process that already
currently exists we appreciate and
understand the path that representative
Merchant would like to pursue regarding
creating additional options for pharmacy
permitting within the state of New
Hampshire however as I stated we do have
some concerns regarding The Proposal
within the language there is no
legislative intent or directive as to
what exactly the Board of Pharmacy
should promulgate rules for our
understanding is that representative
Merchant envisions that the board
develop rules for numerous Specialties
and additional permitting types we also
understand that this process is subject
to and allows consideration of public
comment along with legislative approval
without additional intent in the bill
we're concerned that any permit type
that would seek to govern our practice
would be uh will be overly
burdensome I will remind the committee
that we are already subject to Federal
Regulations that we follow USP 797 and
800 guidelines that are certified by the
quality on and are certified by the
quality oncology practice initiative
under the American Society of clinical
oncology we will never have the
complexity of drugs nor will we have the
volume of drugs coming through our
practice that other retail institutional
pharmacies have finally while we know
that New Hampshire is unique our
neighbors in Maine and Vermont have
already passed narrow regulations for
the practice of physician dispensing in
their states we would request that
similar a similar concept be adopted
here again we stop this change in order
to for us to better serve our patients
without any unnecessary delays to better
ensure coordination between our
providers and patients and to optimize a
patient's adherence to their treatment
thank you for your time today and I'd be
happy to take questions okay thank you
um m do you want to speak first or or do
you want to no I'm just here to answer
any questions
okay okay representative kersman thank
you Mr chairman um can you just repeat
those two states that you mentioned that
have some limited um physician
dispensing
law well I reference Maine and Vermont
um it's actually much broader than that
but the but Maine and Vermont are the
you know because they're immediately
adjacent to us but there are the this
our efforts here have been supported Ed
by a practice similar to ours in Maine
who has an office in Portsmith and they
have they have essentially much fewer um
regulations than what we what has been
discussed here if I can just follow up
on that representative um in Maine in
Vermont um they the um statuto there
statutory language in both states that
allows for physician dispensing of drugs
um with very limited um oversight
regarding storage and labeling
and New York as well there it's there
there are many other states in the in
the country that are where that's true
but the there's there's different rules
kind of throughout the country but but
um I know New York is also has a has a
very simple
exception followup thank you um can you
delve into a little bit further about
the um oversight on storage and labeling
and what you would rather see here
compared to the other
states so um I do have um only one copy
um but I do have copies of what is
applicable um law in Maine and Vermont
um and excuse me um in Vermont it's um
basically that Physicians who dispense
regulated drug shall have fixed to The
Container a label showing the dispensing
practitioners name address and registry
number the name address and the patient
kind and form of the drug contained um
um unless the dispensing practitioner
considers that information should not be
specified um in the date of the issuance
of the prescription in the drug um and
then in main um Physicians are allowed
to dispense um as long as they have the
proper and safe storage of drugs and
devices and the maintenance of proper
records for drugs and devices um and
then there's a whole section on labeling
as well which is pretty similar to what
uh Vermont
has
follow thank thank you and what do you
see the um regulations potentially being
without the legislative intent um that
the Board of Pharmacy might come up with
or Institute for these um for the
pharmacies here that would be different
from
Maine and Vermont I mean I'm not really
sure that we can speak to that because
we have not had we've had a couple of
discussions with a few members of the
Board of Pharmacy but we don't know
right now what those would be um and I
think that
to some degree we would be willing to
you know have some sort of regulations
in place that were similar for storing
and and labeling um but obviously the
the devil's in the details and um we
don't know what the Board of Pharmacy
Weber so am I right to understand that
in in Maine and Vermont there is no
oversight by the Board of Pharmacy at
all it's just done under the physic Ians
or providers
license yes and no um in Vermont my
understanding is that it's done under
the well it says possession and control
of regulated drugs so it must be done
under the pharmacy statute um and then
in main it is the um under the the
pharmacy act but I'm not sure what kind
of reg whether the Board of Pharmacy
comes in to inspect um and I guess to
that point to
um New Hampshire oncology hematology is
um under the jurisdiction of the Board
of Pharmacy and I think we've mentioned
that a couple of times with their
infusion practice the Board of Pharmacy
is currently um able to come in and
inspect um should they they believe that
something um arise is has come up or is
going on um and you know we would pretty
much like to see something similar that
transition to oral anti-cancer medicine
as well um I know just from my
conversations with the with the main
practice that the uh the Board of
Pharmacy does not come in to their
office and um um they're not directly
involved with with the with their oral
dispensing operation
there follow so I'm needing some CL
clarification as a result of that last
answer which is that um if our Board of
Pharmacy here in New Hampshire is
infusions how is what this amendment
proposes which is simply to give them
broader Authority in other cases going
to make things any different than the
overseeing of infusions that they
already do I'm not understanding why
this makes things more difficult for
you well I I think as Gina said a minute
ago I think it all depends on the on the
details of the of what those rules are
so the right now it I I think as as
we've discussed with Doc with u
representative
Merchant um having some broad rules that
would sort of um mirror what we've done
over the years with the Board of
Pharmacy I think that would that would
that would not be of a concern for us
but we don't know what those rules will
be and um and you could easily imagine
them
um being more restrictive which could
create which could create issues for us
follow up
sure why would they be more
restrictive with the prescription of
pills than they are with
infusions so I I see represent Merchant
over in the corner kind of raising his
hand and you will correct me if I'm
wrong
representative my understanding is that
there's sort of an agreement between the
Board of Pharmacy and the Board of
Medicine regarding the inspection of
Physicians practices relative to
infusions that there's no rule so to
speak in place and I could be completely
wrong but that was my
understanding may I speak May answer it
sure um what transpired several years
ago was the confusion between
compounding and Drug preparation
and it created a lot of tension between
the Board of Pharmacy and the Board of
Medicine
that created us down a path where when
you're looking at something that's
following strictly the package insert
that at that point in time is considered
drug preparation and not under the Board
of Pharmacy per se if you deviate from
the package insert which a lot of
chemotherapy does today once you do that
then you're under the jurisdiction of
the Board of Pharmacy is your
compounding not finishing the product
preparation from the FDA oversight so
that's where we have Pharmacy oversight
because compounding is strictly a
pharmacy right within the state and
nationally so that's where the Board of
Pharmacy goes into the clinics to be
sure that when they're doing compounding
it's being done correctly aseptically
and so forth so the board has a
oversight in that Arena but they
following strictly the package insert
and and not deviating from it it's Dru
compounding and I think just to clarify
too and I um just checked with Dr Crow
um New Hampshire oncology hematology has
infusions that they um administer that
are separate from the chemo
administration too which as represent
Merchant just mentioned is is two
completely different things relative to
compounding and
um the other one
reconstitution it's is cor preparation
because basically what happens is when
the product is
manufactured it comes in a powder
sometimes lopiz and a vial or some form
that you have to take a last step before
you can use it for a patient so you have
to take the powder if you will and Recon
it with some sort of solution in order
to create infusion and that's considered
following the package insert by the
FDA once you change like I said you take
any deviation from that package insert
you're considered to be compounding and
that's where the
separation representative representative
mlan thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question I think it's my
understanding one of the Genesis of this
amendment uh was the fact that there was
concern that you know we're dealing with
some very powerful drugs here and that
if there was an error or Omission or
something that happened you know with
respect to administering the drugs and
so the purpose of the amendment is to
kind of bring in an independent double
check okay to kind of put the brakes on
to have something outside of you know
what you're doing to stop pause and
verify um and I didn't see anything that
kind of addressed that in the original
bill so my understanding is that concern
still exists absent this amendment so
can you speak to um Maine can you speak
to Vermont can you speak to your own
practice as to how that concern would be
addressed
absent this
amendment
um I'll try to answer your question then
if I don't answer it please let me know
and I can try again um so the um there
are the the clinical issues with with
prescribing and administering the
treatments and then there are there's
kind of the Regulatory and oversight
stuff so the in terms of the the
clinical issues with my
prescribing chemotherapy or as G was
referring to some of these other
adjunctive drugs that we give in the
office those I write a prescription
they're prepared the within the office
our Pharmacy oversees the the you know
the the actual order to make sure that
it's appropriate our our farm techs
prepare it there's a double check to
make sure that it's prepared correctly
the nurses triple check it to make sure
that it's being that everything is the
way it should be there's a whole process
that goes through with that and the same
thing would happen to a more limited
degree with oral prescriptions they're
they're less complicated than the
infusions because instead of our having
to reconstitute and and sort and um go
through that whole process it's a
prescription but we would have the we
would have similar checks in place for
that I think in terms of maybe what
you're getting at with the question
though is there's there are the
regulatory there's the regulatory
oversight of the whole practice and
making sure that things are being done
in a way where the where the right the
where where the right processes are in
place and where the the the um medicines
are being the particularly the
intravenous medicines are being prepared
in a sterile Manner and and um all those
other factors those are there are many
um different layers of Regulation that
we go through as I alluded to before
there federal regulations that we go
through uh that we have to comply with
in order to for to have our our Pharmacy
in place and so those those things are
are already there we have to meet
various um Quality metrics for um some
of them are are for you know are are
General accreditation and then some of
them are for when we when we're working
with an insurance company to make sure
that you know that that that were kind
of approved particularly with the oral
medications we'd have to sort of show
that we're doing things in the right way
so those things are all in place and
they're the the they I will say with
great confidence that there are that
there are many different layers of of
quality control in the way that that our
are that these prescriptions are are
handled um in the office and um and I
think to to the last point of your
question I think in Maine and in in
Vermont quite frankly I think what has
been decided is there's enough oversight
in those other manner in those other
areas that they don't need that that
they don't need State oversight uh for
that follow up thank you Mr chair and
you know I'm not trying to be difficult
I'm just really trying to understand so
um so you're so you're talking about you
know the thing is done it's checked then
the nurse checks it so this all sounds
like best practice um but there may be
differences you know uh facility to
facility so those best practices that
you're talking about are those already
regulated or is that just something that
you internally have implemented um or is
that something that's already regulated
that these best practices must be done
as part of that framework that you were
talking about a little bit of both so
the the the federal Pharmacy regulations
those are those are there and and you
know you have to meet those and those
are you know those are those are those
are not sort optional essentially um
some of the other sort of the layers
that I was talking about those are more
best practices and you don't you don't
100% need to do those things and and um
but I think most I would say most
oncology practices do do those things
and I think because there's a whole
another layer to this which is which is
getting reimbursed and if we will not
get reimbursed if we can't if we can't
demonstrate the quality of the practice
the quality of our practice so that's
all outside of Regulation and other
stuff that's the real world stuff about
about getting about getting paid and
absolutely that is a factor with the
oral prescriptions that um you know
we're we are happy to assume the
responsibility of Meeting those other
metrics because we know that a it's good
for patients and B we're confident in
our ability to do
it and I think I would just add but this
is the first step the first step is
getting legislative Clarity that legally
they are able to dispense these drugs
and then all of the other things will
come after and there's a huge amount of
cost associated with those things and so
this is I think we talked about this in
the previous hearing but we we can't
commit to spending to to spending all
that money as an independent practice
unless we know that we're going to be
able that we're not going to run a foul
of of state law and that's why we've
been kind of stuck with
this yeah representative Lon um thank
you Mr chairman and thank you doctor for
being here um I'm hoping I could use
your expertise for um to answer a
question related to another bill that
had started in this committee and is
over in finance um currently are there
therapies available for every um cancer
or are we still looking for therapies
for
some uh well that's a hard one to answer
there are therapies I the there are some
cancers where there are fewer and less
effective therapies so you could kind of
debate um you know they're very there's
no cancer that I can think of where
there is nothing that we would ever talk
about with a patient but there's some
there there are some there actually more
than I would like circumstances where we
have those conversations and we don't
have treatments in which we have great
confidence and and so there's more of a
discussion about should we do something
rather than you know what are we going
to do thank you that was incredibly
helpful thank you reprentative Murphy
and then representative kushman thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
my question just from you know forget
the regulatory part of it forget all the
oversight Etc how would this bill
without this bill and without the bill
as amended how will this affect the
quality of care that you were able to
give your
patients well it undermines quality of
care thatf typically how
so as things exist now with these oral
medicines I do a
prescription our office goes through an
extensive financial review with
insurance to see what's going to cover
and you know what the out of pocket's
going to be all the all these other
things I then it the the prescription
gets reviewed by our pharmacist and
everything everybody else and our nurses
to make sure that it's appropriate it
gets sent to a specialty Pharm
typically out of state very rarely in
state they that then gets filled and and
sent to the to the patient we have to
coordinate with the patient when to
start it and there's off you it's a
surprisingly complicated thing to do
that because people get confused
something arrives in the mail and they
think I'm going to start taking it
tomorrow and we want to make sure that
we're all on the same page about when
they start it and then as I think we
discussed
previously most of these medicines we
see a patient well well our nurses call
and and touch base make sure things are
going okay we see a patient a week or
two after they've started the medicine
we check their blood CS or other labs
and then we have to we we often have to
hold the medicine and reduce the dose
but at that point the when the
prescriptions are being are being filled
by a specialty pharmacy it's very hard
to coordinate those changes in real time
with a specialty pharmacy so the
prescriptions are either being sent too
early at the wrong dose or they're being
sent late and delaying treatment or
we're having to to sort of make up a
dose to sort of modify because they get
500 milligram pills and we want to
reduce it by 100 milligram you know so
so there's all kinds of of compromises
that we have to make clinically in order
to to to uh adjust for those
inefficiencies and if we were to do what
has been proposed with this
conversation I would see a patient I
would say I'm going to reduce the dose
by whatever amount that would again be
reviewed by our staff and everything and
then the patient would go to the
pharmacy in the office and get the new
prescription have it in hand when they
leave the office and be ready to make
the adjustments as we discussed so
that's the simplest version of it sorry
for not being simple thank you that's
very helpful because it does give a a
sense about the quality of care so the
follow-up question to that is that if
this bill were not passed or passed as
amended would it impact you negatively
financially in your practice yes it
would okay thank you
representative kushman thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking
another question
um M uh representative McLean's question
kind of got me thinking um you've got
pharmacists in your practice to be that
check on the prescriptions on the on the
Physicians orders if this amendment as
I'm reading it um would basically allow
any physician to get a pharmacy
dispensing license um for dispensing
medication from their
practice um would that second check with
that pharmac pharmacist oversight then
be removed in those
circumstances well and I I don't want to
get um outside my Lane here but um I'll
give you my opinion so
um our
practice a big part of what we do is we
do chemotherapy so that's that is how we
take care of our patients that's how we
generate Revenue um the uh so we have
all these PL all these structures in
place um be because we need to for for
oral anlytics or for analytics in
general we need those structures in
place and that is true for oral
analytics as
well when the when the bill was
originally written in the Senate It Was
Written very narrow
because
our situation is unique in medicine
there really is no other situation in
medicine where the where infusion where
these types of treatments are are
prominent a prominent enough part of the
practice that that you'll have a
pharmacist and a and all those other
structures in place there's many areas
where it's kind of started to expand
that way but not to a degree where for
example in Rheumatology or Dermatology
or where where some of these things are
given there's just not enough volume
there for them to to make the investment
they would need to in order to create
those those types of those types of
support systems and I think if you when
you open it
up it makes it more complicated it makes
it more complicated for the Board of
Pharmacy um because they're going to
need to sort of put in those to put in
those those protections because what we
do is just not the same as what other
what other parts of medicine do um and
and I will say to to go back to a
question from before you know why would
the rules be complicated I think my
concern and I I My Hope Is and it sounds
like maybe the rules would not be
complicated but my concern is that as
rules are created to cover other
Specialties in medicine they will then
start to to lose the they'll start to
put lose the the put more uh
restrictions that are not really um
gerine to what we do but but they'll
have because it's a broader because it's
a you're covering broader circumstances
there you kind of Lo it's it it gets
more complicated and um the and that's
you know that would be that would be
part of my concern about
it representative South King thank you
Mr chair very quick question no
explanation needed would you you prefer
us to pass the original unamended Bill
the amended or
nothing I would prefer to pass the
original unamended Bill thank you other
questions seeing none thank you I think
there's just one more thing um that I
forgot to mention so um we have a letter
here from um executive director Lindsay
Courtney um we had talked with her about
whether or not she believed that um
there may need to be a statutory fix in
order for um New Hampshire oncology he
ology to um get a pharmacy license and
um o she says in part oplc takes no
position on the bill however oplc
believes a statutory change may be
needed to clarify which licensing board
has authority to regulate the dispensing
of certain medications by healthc care
providers who choose to work with a
pharmacist in the circumstances under
which such medications may be dispensed
so I'm just going to leave copies of
this for all of you okay thank you
representative Weber so just so I'm that
was the same is that the same letter
that gave rise to this whole thing or is
this something completely new and does
it relate to the underlying Bill the
amendment or
what so this is not the original letter
that gave rise to this that was a
declaratory ruling that gave rise to
this um this was a letter I believe it's
dat April 25th it was the um a letter
that she um sent uh or had available um
regarding the underlying Bill okay so
it's it's specific to the underlying
Bill
correct and just as I listened to it was
she saying that there might be more
needed than just what was in the
underlying bill or was she saying that
the underlying bill I mean you really
um are you reading that as saying that
the underlying Bill needed more work or
are you reading it as saying that the
underlying bill was what was clarifying
I don't I don't want to speak for
director Courtney but my understanding
is that the letter was in response
basically to the questions that have
Arisen that keep getting brought up that
New Hampshire oncology
hematology is able to currently get a
license from the Board of Pharmacy which
we have maintained that we cannot
legally based on the rules um under pH
2300 and I think this was just her
saying yes we agree that a statutory
that statutory clarification may be
necessary in order for them to do this
and and one last followup and and that
was made clear with the declaratory
ruling is that not correct well we
believe so but we know that others do
not believe the same thing okay thank
you representative Merchant you have a
comment more of a comment just history
here
what happened was they went to the Board
of Pharmacy under the so what triggered
this whole thing and came out of it was
the fact that the Board of Pharmacy and
uh executive
Courtney said the statute of the way
it's written is confusing to if we can
bring Clarity to the statute then she
felt more comfortable the board could do
what the uh practice is asking them to
do is issue the license but we didn't
have that Clarity at the time so it's
fundamentally what this bill's trying to
do
you also signed up to speak is Tanya
Carlton from The New Hampshire Society
Pharmacy you've asked for three
minutes yeah good morning representative
McDonald and members of the committee
I'm here to testify in support of
Representative Merchant's Amendment
which will allow for the Board of
Pharmacy uh to promulgate rules which
will um assist with ensuring safe um
medication dispensing as well as I think
it will also um alleviate representative
kushman's concern that she had brought
up earlier related to ensuring that um
it's not not just you know a provider
providing these medications but there is
oversight as well in terms of double
checks um when you do have a pharmacist
or Pharmacy involved um we are double
cheing for medication interactions to
ensure that these medic medications are
manner thank Youk you any
you no one has else has signed up to
testify on this amendment does anyone
else wish to
testify seeing none um representative
sheet who signed up in favor if no one
else uh representative Lon is checking
to see who made have registered online
yes Amendment 1725 H online it's hard to
tell if it was New or Old but there were
two in support and six opposed I don't
know if that was the what the bill we
initially heard or this amendment okay
thank you all right with that I'm going
to close the public hearing on this uh
on this Amendment um again 2024 D7 25h
to Senate Bill 458 I'm closing that
public hearing and opening the public
hearing on uh Amendment uh to SB
20505 uh which is
39h and recognize the sponsor of this
amendment representative Eric ala um
thank you Mr chairman and I will bring
you a pink card as I sit back down for
the record I'm Erica Lon and I represent
the town of dairy um the there's a lot
that's going on in um cannabis and hemp
and what not this year um there's a
large move that may end up with full
legal with legalization of cannabis um
and or it may not actually succeed this
year uh last year um a bill to regulate
the hemp derived products was attached
to um another bill that we had had it
was part of the effort where there was
an agreement to have the study
commission over the summer and into the
fall to meet with the intention of
introducing legislation for the legal
legalization of cannabis um that
committee did not actually emerge with
legislation and um for those in favor
fortunately somebody introduced it for
those in not in favor unfortunately
somebody introduced that legislation
however the um in the committee of
conference the prohibition on
intoxicating hemp ey products had a
Sunset date because there was an
agreement that there would be movement
there would be legalization before this
was extended this was done in order to
make sure that people were willing to
come together have a decision and figure
out how to finally get this done um
because of that simply coming along and
um getting rid of the Sunset date
without actually legalizing recreational
Cannabis um seems to violate that
agreement that we had in the committee
of conference what I've done within this
amendment is that I have given a pathway
to have some regulations for the hemp
derived um THC products because we've
seen some pretty appalling packaging
from things that are being offered to
our um tobacco outlets they're being
told that some of these packagings that
look like sour patch kits and they s
Sour Diesel kids other things like that
that they're totally fine and they're
acceptable in the state it's deceptive
packaging they don't always have the
correct labeling we don't know what's in
them because the state has nothing to do
with the testing what this does is it
has a very Bare Bones mimic of what
would be set up and established within
legalization of cannabis itself to allow
testing for potency for um contaminants
like residual solvents poisons or toxins
harmful chemicals dangerous molder mildo
filth dangerous pesticides and
fungicides heavy metals and harmful
microbial such as ecoli and salmonella
and also the cannaboid and THC potency
um as well as the isomer so that you
know what you're getting so there are
two naturally occurring um that Delta 8
Delta 9 I'm actually not knowledgeable
enough to remember which one of is the
traditional cannabis we think of and
which is the one that's in hemp um but
those are the two that grow in nature um
there's all sorts of other ones that I
like to call Franken weed that they
create in a lab that are all these other
I
those ones nobody really knows anything
about and the idea permitting those in
the state when they're just some lab
created derivative um just is a bridge
too far for me even though I generally
believe that people should be able to
make some make decisions on Lower risk
things that they consume so this
amendment is to instead of just having
an outright ban give a barebones
regulatory structure and uh for this
because generally the people who would
be selling it are
are the tobacco outlets having making
sure that the lenses need to comply with
the provisions of this section would
then address this um and would make it
so that if they're selling this
misleading packaging there's a
consequence for them and they don't want
to give up their licensing so that's
going to be a good way to make sure that
they are in fact staying within the
guidelines um ideally this also um
hopefully I hopefully this bill can just
stand on its own assuming that that the
other bill that it was supposed to be
paired with moves forward in the Senate
and actually moves towards adoption but
ultimately I would like to also see um
the Cannabis legalization that passed
out of the house attached to this on the
floor just to ensure that that attention
and in agreement during the committee of
conference that these other hemp derived
thc's um would have a Sunset date on the
prohibition in unless we were able to
get to legalization is truly carried out
so step one is making sure that we have
a framework for this regulation and that
is in this amendment too we can't get to
step two until we get to the house floor
so with that I'm happy to take any
questions representative Weber and then
representative
Shapiro thank you for this and thank you
for that
explanation just because I'm loath to go
back and look in the chapter law and I
am reading the underlying bill which
of the prohibition is repealed so I've
got three negatives so am I correct in
thinking
that if we do nothing with the bill if
we pass the underlying Bill the
prohibition stays in place is that
correct or have I gotten that the wrong
way round um so I'm just going to give a
statement as opposed to answering that
what passed was a Prohibition that had a
Sunset date this fall what the bill
underlying Bill does is it reveals
repeals that Sunset date so the
prohibition would continue on into the
future into the sunset um so if we had
no action then it the repeal would stand
um if we passed the underlying bill then
then it stays forever thank you very
much for that clarification that helps
me a lot thank you representative
Shapiro and then representative South
King thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for indulging me because I haven't read
this carefully maybe it's it's in here
but um who would actually be responsible
for the testing and the um the expense
of testing well thank you for that
question the products would need to be
tested in order to be sold so because
the hemp derived products could be
manufactured out of state and then
brought in state because they don't V
violate any federal laws and therefore
don't have any Interstate restrictions
um if there is a Testing Lab out of
state that can meet those requirements
for labeling than the pro than the
person who is making this could do that
and have it tested out of state um
assuming that we do pass legalization
those testing Labs should also be able
to do what is necessary in order to test
these hemp derive products as well um so
assuming that these two go hand inand
that will the the further part will be
fleshed out within the language of the
underlying legalization Bill
1633 um and this would just piggyback on
it
follow so I see under categories of
um things to be tested um to um find
threshold amounts one of them is
filth um and is that a is that a
clinical term is there something that's
specific that is filth um thank you for
the question uh that's one of those
things that has survived and has been
included in the ongoing process towards
legalization of what the testing
requirements are I took that language
directly from the 1633 language um so
that's why it's included although quite
frankly I'm still not sure how you test
for Filth but you know what if a lab can
do it that's great and if not um it'll
probably end up being a test with a
threshold where it's essentially nothing
and then we can fix it in law or they
can just fix it through rule by making
it um a non- test if it's required and
it doesn't make sense thank you I didn't
think it was you that you came up with
it no representative Seth King and then
representative Merchant thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative for
drafting this amendment I really didn't
like how the original was the language
it was unclean and this is so much more
explicit which I appreciate um one of
the things we heard in testimony on the
original bill which really struck a
chord with me is the idea that these
hemp products are getting people sick
and potentially as a result is really
giving cannabis a bad name and so people
will go to the hospital and then people
who don't really understand the issue
are going to be like oh that's cannabis
for you look at it look at all the
people that's making sick and it's like
no this isn't this isn't this isn't the
Cannabis we're all used to and have been
fighting for for decades this is
something totally different if if your
Amendment passes and gets signed into
law is that going to help do you believe
with the issues that we're seeing that
are inadvertently hurting the B merching
that the canis name uh thank you that's
a very good question so when you look at
the delta Delta 9 and I'm sorry I still
forget which one is which um but there's
a lot more knowledge of that one it's
these other isomers that they're
creating that seem that are the ones
where they're starting to see some
signals of a lot of harm um that's why
basically this bill keeps all of those
illegal but it simply allows for those
naturally growing ones to then be
distilled down because if you're going
to take something that's under under the
3% um that's yes under the 3% on a dry
weight basis there are ways that you can
um concentrate that down and you can do
that obviously it's a chemical process
but it's not going to be as intensive as
if you're creating this other stuff in a
lab um and quite frankly I'm prob going
to see that most people are probably
going to move to uh prefer the natural
grown product over this um however I
think that it's also important to give
options so people aren't getting other
unregulated ones across uh state borders
either if they for some reason do like
um these types of products thank you
representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair and also
thank you representative for bringing
this forward and I want to commend you
for trying to
uh find a solution to a product I think
does have some merits in the
marketplace a couple of questions I
have it goes back to it sounds like this
is creating more standards on production
so therefore
people in the state of New Hampshire if
they're buying these particular products
have some faith in what's going on with
what they're buying so that's the intent
of the standards is that where you're
trying to go um thank you for the
question so the intent of it is so that
there are guidelines that the
manufacturers have to meet so that when
a vendor has somebody say do you want to
buy this you know it's it's allowed
under state law there actually are some
Frameworks for what is allowed under
state law because most of these
retailers are calling and well there's
at least some that are calling and
asking when it's in state law those that
aren't calling and asking probably will
well soon because the Liquor Commission
is very good at following up with people
who are not following their rules follow
up follow
up and talking about the enforcement
part of
it given the fact many of these products
are obtained through the mail mail order
uh from locations outside of the
jurisdiction of New Hampshire how would
that be handled uh thank you for the
question a lot of this is just focused
on the retail Market because since this
is not federally prohibited this has
sprung up as a new market it's one that
in the state we just said absolutely
none but there are some that are that
are still available in other places so
the biggest part is you walk in you see
something on the Shelf you ask if it's
legal they say it is um the question is
has it been tested so you know what's in
it and so that what the label says is
true you know people need to be able to
make a decision at a certain point but
if you have false labeling or if you
false claims then that should not be
acceptable and that should not be
allowed to be sold in the state um
without this framework you can't do that
so that's how this framework brings us
from the wild west that we were in and
moves us into a more regulated scheme um
without Banning it outright thank you
other
you also signed up to speak is Matt
good
morning you've asked for five minutes if
you could keep it closer to three I'd
chairman good morning everybody for the
record Matt Simon Granite Leaf
cannabis
um I've already spoken you at length on
these topics so I'll try to say new
things that are focused on the amendment
amendment so I've given you two handouts
that I've created one is problems with
the amendment the other is an attempt to
illustrate some contrasting
policies um how would Amendment 17398
treat these
products so I'll start with the biggest
problem we have here um the house is
already passed HB
1633 1633 would authorize The Liquor
Commission regulate the production and
sale of hemp derived intoxicating
cannabinoids notably hp1 1633 stipulates
that regulations for intoxicating hemp
products quote may not be less
restrictive than the regulations for
natural cannabis this amendment would
directly contradict and undermine that
policy uh by legalizing the sale of THC
pro products without effective
regulation it's one thing to use that
word regulation is another thing to have
an actual regulated system and
unfortunately this amendment doesn't and
can't create a regulated system for
these products which are all produced in
other
states so just to illustrate on on the
side by side column A is the therapeutic
cannabis program laws and rules column B
is the house positions on adult use
cannabis regulation which are in
hb33 and the third column is the much
less restrictive and unenforceable
standards that would be created by this
amendment um so I won't go through all
of them but a few of the big ones
are lab testing for canabo and
contaminants yes absolutely I think we
can all agree that these products should
be lab tested there's simply no way for
a New Hampshire regulator to require or
verify that they've been tested in
another
state all of these products or at least
most of them I've seen include test
results a lot of them have QR code you
can look it up right there test results
what do those mean to me they mean
absolutely nothing because these
products were not produced within a
regulated system I'll explain how our
system works with the TCP we have all of
our products every single batch tested
by an independent lab the lab reports
those results to the ATC and to the
Department of Health and Human Services
and they're able to verify that every
label on every product that we have
includes the accurate batch specific lab
testing results for our products HP 1633
envisions a similar if not identical
type of system in New Hampshire we would
essentially be Outsourcing those
regulations to other states and
ultimately to companies themselves and
trusting them to
self-regulate um packaging so for both
the therapeutic cannabis program and in
HB
1633 patch Packaging must be opaque and
child
resistant uh that requirement does not
exist in this
amendment access to stores where
products and sold you can't get into an
ATC unless you are a registered patient
or caregiver you can't get into an adult
cannabis retail outlet established by
1633 unless you're 21 and older but any
person of any age can enter stores where
synthetic THC is
sold uh sales would be limited to 21
plus but there's no restriction in here
displayed next we get into the
definitions and this is where I'll try
not to be confusing um but you've heard
that Delta 8 and Delta 9 are naturally
produced that's not really true so Delta
8 does occur in Trace Amounts in nature
uh my understanding is that 100% of the
derived Delta 8 product products that
are sold are synthesized because you
cannot grow enough delta8 to harvest it
you could start wrapping up
please
okay trying to be responsive to the
testimony that's been raised Del 9
there'll be questions anyway I'm sure
okay Delta 9 THC is the one the people
who've been using cannabis for years are
familiar with the definition of hemp and
let's understand that cannabis and hemp
are the same plant the only difference
is this arbitrary definition it's in
federal law and state law that if it's
below 3% Delta 9 THC it's hemp if it's
above that amount it's THC or it's yeah
it's a it's marijuana or or cannabis so
this amendment I mean the definitions
are are very
problematic
um if the intention is to only legalize
natural Delta hthc that doesn't exist
so um I assume the intention is to
legalize synthetic
THC Delta 9 THC that's made from hemp is
synthetic just as surely as Delta H THC
that's made from hemp is synthetic you
grow the CBD you soak it in acid you
make
THC that's how it's made so I would
argue that if these labels don't include
the word synthetic then they're falsely
and misleadingly
labeled um the biggest thing is we
simply can't impose regulations on other
states The Liquor Commission can look at
labels and say I think this counts or
this doesn't count but there's no way
whatsoever to know so this amendment
would create the illusion of
regulation in place of actual regulation
I'll conclude and answer questions any
questions representative Seth King thank
you Mr chair and thank you for your
testimony are you concerned that if the
amendment is passed or if underlying the
original bill is not passed that these
so-called
synthetic THC products are going to be a
threat to the passage of HB
1633 representative I don't see this
bill as having anything whatsoever to do
with
1633 this is about trying
to take advantage of a loophole and make
it permanent I know that's I don't think
that's the intention but I think that's
what would be the result it would
normalize and legitimize the sale of
products that are fundamentally more
dangerous and riskier than natural
cannabis normalizing their sale at gas
stations and convenience
stores while simultaneously we're trying
to create a responsibly regulated
cannabis market so Vermont has developed
a reputation for craft cannabis by
licensing hundreds of small Growers uh
Maine has developed a similar reputation
New Hampshire's reputation would be
synthetic
THC and I think that's a very poor very
poor example to set and a very poor
direction to go so I would encourage you
to view these as completely separate
they did wind up in the same bill that
created the study commission that's
because the house sent the original Bill
to interim study and the Senate kept
attaching this to other things they
ended up attaching it to the commission
bill so they wound up being lumped
together but they're entirely separate
issues I view this in the same way that
I viewed uh the synthetic marijuana
debates from 10 years
ago uh these products are people want
natural
THC if they grew it it would be a felony
in New Hampshire it's legal in every
other New England State but it's a it'
be a crime here uh I would just urge you
if you want to make a stand for Freedom
fight for hom grow fight for access to
the plant don't fight for synthetic THC
and gas stations it undermines The
credibility of the hemp industry it
undermines The credibility of the
Cannabis industry and it creates
confusion while I was here testifying on
this bill a few weeks ago one of my
former students from Kentucky sent me a
message and says hey I've been vaping
THC products I have a few questions for
you and turns out he had no idea they
were synthetic products that he was
buying in Kentucky one of them was
giving me a colossal colossal headache
why everybody lumps us together
um thank you for your uh your answer are
are you sure that
the the side effects the negative side
effects of the synthetics are not from
just the poor quality control the filth
that's in them as opposed to the uh as
opposed to the actual synthesized
THC I think the problem is not the THC
itself because Delta 8 THC I think is is
probably a safe canabo and if it's
produced Within actually regulated
market I think it's just fine I think
the issue is probably the the residual
solvents the acid not being properly
removed from the product and people
think these are natural products they
see strain names on them and think that
it's a strain of cannabis that's been
grown it is somebody bought a kilo of
THC oil that was produced by a CBD
company they added turpins to it and it
is posing as as a cannabis product what
one last Quick followup one last
followup um but the amendment is my
understanding is that its goal is to
regulate it so that it doesn't have
excess solvents and all these other
things in there I mean isn't that a good
thing it's a wonderful intention it is
simply impossible to do in practice
because no regulator in New Hampshire is
able to require or verify the lab
testing unless the state where it's
produced has a responsibly regulated
system I'm not aware of any state that
has a responsibly regulated system
people are doing whatever the hell they
want and they're calling it cannabis
very good thank you representative
Weber thank you Mr chair and thank you
thank you for taking my question um so
to go back to the beginning I'm just s
trying to sort out again and I'm sure
you gave us this as your testimony
before but you are in favor of the
underlying bill unamended is that
correct yes okay and if uh and you're
opposed to this um do you have an
opinion as to the
advisability of trying to put this and
then put the cannabis bill that's
already in the Senate on it as
well and if you don't have an opinion
about that that's fine I just wanted to
know if you had one my opinion is that
we should abandon any illusion that New
Hampshire can effectively regulate the
production of products in other states
and that's that's what would have to
happen here so just since you asked
earlier the the the line that would be
repealed or not repealed just says
nothing in this chapter shall be
construed to authorize the sale of
products that are derived from hemp
which contain natural or synthetic
tetrah hydroc canaban greater than 0.3%
on a dry weight basis which appear in
any formulation including Delta 8 Delta
9 or any other THC iser variant so I
view the original law and the law we're
trying to not repeal here as being basic
Common Sense clarifying the intent of
the legislature when it passed the hemp
law nobody thought they were legalizing
THC sales at gas stations I don't think
effective cannabis policy gets made by
exploiting loopholes I think it's made
by thoughtful
deliberation thank you very much
representative Murphy and then
representative Nagel thank you thank you
very much Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question hopefully you can
clear up some of my confusion because I
wrot down here last time you were here
Mr Simon you supported the bill correct
and your your statement was that THC
product should be
regulated and house bills 1633 basically
allows or allows THC but regulated
within the state for the sale within the
state right so you are all in favor of
that you're opposed to the
amendment because it attempts to
regulate
stuff filthy stuff that comes from out
of state is that
correct
correct so you would you you support
1633 you support because it's state
regulated you support you know regulated
THC and you support the ongoing
prohibition that would be present in the
current bill is that correct yes
representative and if it's helpful my
general positions on this issue are
pretty identical to the position papers
I've handed out from normal and doctors
for drug policy reform essentially THC
products should be regulated and
synthetic THC product should be
regulated at least as restrictively As
Natural
THC so your incentive here really is to
make it so that the product that is
ultimately out there that regulated by
the state is a good product is a safe
product so that you know that cannabis
can then be sold within the state in a
controlled manner
in a safe manner okay yes I just want to
be clear about your position in but also
what you said previously thank you thank
you representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question I
I I just want to make sure I understand
two things first um the original bill is
still in the amended version
correct in other words the prohibition
of the prohibition the prohibition
repeal thing the number one that's still
in there correct or is that totally
gone because it says add a add this
paragraph after number one
representative we do you have a
clarification
or subject to uh representative Lyon's
correction of my cor
clarification um there is in the
amendment the fact that uh
the because it says amend the bill by
after if you look at at section lines 19
to 21 representative Lon does have yeah
yeah I want to hear um thank you that
actually was a drafting error because
that would then repeal everything that
we would be creating there um it was
just a matter of hitting up against the
deadlines to get this into the calendar
so that is an error so okay because what
it says here is amend by after section
one so this implies section one which is
the repeal still exists but it doesn't
exist that was not my intent my intent
was instead of repealing to have the
regulatory scheme oh okay all right so
will that be amended to change that then
all depends what we decide as a
committee okay so we're going to vote on
what here what's here right now is is is
section one from the original Bill still
exists is that correct um so we couldn't
really touch 439 d a because without an
non- derain amendment because we were
only at chapter law by opening up that
section of the rsas we needed an on
Germain Amendment so to have any changes
within there we needed to open it up
through a non gerain hearing here all
right because that brings me to my
second question which is really more for
you and I think you may be answering my
question already
but I if one still existed it almost
seems to me like the second part's a no
harm no foul but without one it is a
harm and foul to you is that correct I'm
not sure and understand yeah I'm not
sure I understand either I think there's
two very Divergent paths here and I
don't see any future down the path of
trying to impose New Hampshire
regulations on these products so I I
just think this whole thing is a
non-starter and we need to default to
the original Bill and you're happy with
the original Bill the second Bill's
problem at part I got it absolutely now
I understand I think representative we
sorry but but just to pars what we have
in front of us which was what I was
trying to do
um lines um 19 to 21 prohibit anything
that doesn't fall under what's permitted
in here and and your position is so it
does have a
Prohibition um but your position is that
that would be very difficult to police
in the current situation is that correct
correct and I I should applaud that it
does limit to Delta 8 and Delta 9 it it
so this THC product would would be
illegal but this product that's 92%
synthetic Delta 9 Delta 8 THC which
isn't opaquely packaged isn't child
resistant uh says mindbending ghost
train Haze on it and makes you feel
Swifty which is a cartoon reference Rick
and Morty if anybody gets it uh this is
not a regulated product but my
understanding is that it would be legal
and presumably regulated under the
section assuming this QR code points to
an actual lab report of some
kind go ahead follow I'm not going to
get into the questions I have about the
display because it's just beyond what
we're really working on representative
Merchant then representative n thank you
Mr chair and also thank you for taking
the
question in regards to the state law we
can prohibit what we do here in New
Hampshire but there's no prohibition for
mail order in other words a resident
could be ordering it from anywhere else
in the country right so therefore if
they can do that why not try to create
something in New Hampshire that actually
tries to regulate the standards the
guidelines so the the patient or the
consumer has something to follow because
if we can't prohibit other states from
sending it into our residents then what
are we doing yeah thank you for the
question I agree we can't stop mail
order at all and there is no way with or
without this am amendment that New
Hampshire could regulate mail order
delivery of these products the entire
point of the bill is to have these
products not be sold in gas stations
convenience stores in a less restriced
regulatory environment than exist would
exist for natural Canabis and I totally
concur I think what I'm trying to get to
is we can control the retail sale right
in New Hampshire so what this law is
trying to do is be sure that if we're
selling at the retail level at the gas
station wherever it's going to be sold
there's some control over some
guidelines of How It's manufactured it
doesn't mean that they can still ordered
on the mail so if we have at least some
guidelines for something being sold
retail here in New Hampshire aren't we
somehow making a step forward versus
telling people well just buy it on the
mail go to whatever www is ordered that
way there we have no jurisdiction over
it whatsoever representative I I think a
step forward would be passing hb1 1633 I
don't I don't view this as a step
forward in any way because again it
would be the illusion of Regulation it
would not be a reality of Regulation
there's never been a vote in the general
court that affirmatively said where we
want THC products sold at gas stations
and convenience stores I'm 100% certain
that would have failed if it had been
understood to be what was in the hemp
Bill another followup so the illusion I
that I see is that we're sort of saying
to people in New Hampshire you can't buy
it retail but you can buy everywhere
else that's an illusion too because it's
not stopping people from getting it all
we're trying to do at that point in time
is trying to be sure in a state on anry
we don't have any retail sales of it am
I munding something here because
patients can still get
it anybody can still get it if they know
how to operate a website and order it
through the mail there's a very separate
question about these products being
placed in stores where anybody can see
them while we're simultaneously trying
to create a much higher standard for
natural cannabis it just doesn't make
any sense to me
representative naal thank you Mr
chairman thanks again I I just want to
get Circle back so I want to make sure I
understand lines 19 through 21 and what
you've said so far if if we did pass
this amendment in some form or whatever
that um that's the synthetic one you're
talking
about but in this case the Delta 9
that's derived from him would also be
synthetic okay so you would eliminate
both of them then in that in that
setting I would absolutely eliminate
this entire minut I go you all right
thank you representative Paz
off thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question so help me understand
if it's being uh produced uh by
legitimate registered producer in
another state and sold in a legitimate
establishment here and we have
some grievances with headaches of us
like can they just
you uh uh people who sold them with uh
confusing labeling and maybe some
harmful residual acid inside like can't
we just use our current legal system if
people are
harmed representative I think that may
lead to a lot of lawsuits I think the
reality and we've learned this in the
Cannabis industry is that like any other
business there are Bad actors in Vermont
I just saw a headline this morning where
a grower has been cited for the second
time using an illegal
fungicide it looks it appears that they
applied it after having the product lab
tested which I'll never understand uh
the effective regulatory system caught
it before anybody ingested it these
people will almost certainly lose their
license uh people products do fail tests
in regulated systems that actually
verify these things and unfortunately
have programs in other states don't do
that so there's no
McKay thank you Mr chairman Mr Simon
it's good to see you good to see I saw
him uh regularly for five years as we
developed this
program U my concern is the professional
medical committee that has been
established in New Hampshire that is
chaired by one of our former
members and at my age names slip by U
but this Jerry Jerry kerk right uh would
they have any role in uh reviewing these
products so the therapeutic canas
medical oversight board has discussed
this issue uh they determined that it
was outside the scope of the therapeutic
cannabis program so they decided not to
take a position on it I know that former
repres representative kerk strongly
supports effective regulation of all
cannabis products and and does not
support the cell I've discussed this
with him many times he does not think
synthetic THC should be sold in in gas
stations or convenience stores thank you
thank you representative
Shapiro thank you thank you Mr chairman
and thank you for um taking this
question I I don't have a very
sophisticated understanding of these
products I haven't ever seen them in a
convenience store but I obviously I
wasn't looking carefully um but it seems
like there are two categories of
products one um which is described on
line 19 and one that's described on line
29 um
and there there seems to me that they're
um I think we're talking about the same
products in both both of those sections
we so they're the same products I
believe
so one one talks about which appear in
Delta 8 Delta 9 on line
um oh and one talks about other than
that that yeah I'm sorry I misunderstood
and was reading it wrong I think 19 to
21 attempt to prohibit anything that's
not Delta 8 or Delta 9 which is
32 make an exception for those products
right and would redefine I mean the
traditional understanding of s products
is that they're they don't contain THC
so we'd be completely changing the
definition of hemp and basically saying
that hemp is cannabis follow up so
anyway that was just a leadup to
question which is that um if we go with
the original bill which which repeals
the
repeal would would all these products
remain illegal in New Hampshire yes
they'd be clearly illegal under New
Hampshire law and that maybe why you
haven't seen them at convenience stores
is because they are currently illegal
and this amendment seeks to undo so the
so the if we go with the the present
repeal all of them would fall under that
that um prohibition that's correct okay
thank you representative South King
thank you Mr chair thank you again for
um under
1633 um would people be able to have
access to THC vape
products yes okay so people do like to
use that method and and we'd be able to
get that with 1633 um and absolutely
either natural or synthetic
okay and the reason would you say that
the reason why people choose these
synthetic products is really just a
loophole it's to get around current
prohibitions on natural cannabis yes the
research I've seen suggests that these
products are much much much more popular
in States where people don't have access
to real cannabis uh so yeah I I don't
think they're very popular in New
Hampshire frankly I might have more
pause about this if we're talking about
somebody living in Alabama where it's
300 miles nearest cannabis store but
people in New Hampshire have options
they can if they don't want to sign up
for the therapeutic program they can
drive to any neighboring state and there
is a real cannabis store right across
the border that would be a much better
choice than than any of this okay thank
you representative kosman did you have
you hand up earlier
or okay any other
questions see you onone thank you thank
also signed up to speak is Jim Riddle
Hampshire thank you Mr chair members of
the committee my name is Jim Riddle from
Hillsboro I have a USDA hemp grower
license for seed production uh which I
obtained after the DEA a couple years
ago ruled that all cannabis seeds are
hemp uh because they contain no THC
there's zero THC in
seeds
um but I'm not involved in the THC
business one way or another either
natural or synthetic I only deal with
seeds I do serve on the board of uh
Advisory Board of the New Hampshire
cannabis Association and on the policy
Committee of Nova New Hampshire the
organic group but I'm speaking here on
my own behalf today and I have some
concerns about this amendment
1739 which would legalize the sale and
possession of synthetic intoxicating THC
products derived from
hemp
um I've done a lot of work attended a
lot of meetings and really support uh uh
hb1
1633 but I am concerned that this
amendment would uh uh it's contradictory
to the language of 16
33 um 1633 would require that both
natural and synthetic THC products be
tightly regulated in terms of the
testing requirements in terms of how
they're labeled packaged marketed Etc
it's really a comprehensive approach to
both the direct cannabis as well as
these synthesized from hemp uh
intoxicating products but this amendment
would create an end run essentially um
jump starting giving favor uh to the
synthetic THC products while leaving
natural THC products either illegal as
they are now or in regulatory limbo uh
deter you know depending on the fate of
1633 uh and HB 1231 which is the medical
hom grow bill which I think are the two
priority pieces of legislation and 16 33
does have half a page about how
intoxicating hemp products will be
regulated um so this bill though or this
amendment ignores that and gives these
preferential treatments and they can
just jump start uh from out ofate
suppliers instead of building a craft
cannabis and hemp uh industry here in in
the state and i' just like to share a
few points from the doctors for drug
policy reform and their uh positions on
these uh synthetic uh hemp derived
products um they say the licensing
requirements for dispensaries selling
the in intoxicating cannaboid should be
required so these wouldn't be sold by
dispensaries these would be sold by any
gas station or tobacco shop that wants
to sell them there should be taxation to
fund regulatory oversight and public
health initiatives this Amendment
doesn't create any kind of funding for
oversight
mechanism um they should be in
childproof containers clear labeling uh
with the
international symbol uh for cannaboid
content and that this that's ignored in
this you could start wrapping up please
okay thank
you well I just like to also remind you
that this whole thing started because of
a loophole created in the 2018 Farm Bill
uh which legalized the production of
hemp and then uh um that is being
addressed it's a very hot topic as
Congress debates the new Farm Bill uh so
I think you need to be aware of that but
also how it interplays with the dea's
proposed rule to change uh all cannabis
uh from schedule one to schedule three I
think that is going to uh and the one
thing that that has really brought to
light is the
medical uses of cannabis it's not the
intoxicating properties the natural
cannabis it's the Entourage effects of
the tpen that are naturally found and
you can breed for higher tpen that have
more Health promoting properties these
products are purely intoxicating they're
just the THC uh that's been synthesized
from CBD turning it into THC whether
it's Delta 9 or Delta 8 or
uh uh concentrating it again please
please wrap up yes well just as a
licensed hemp grower I'm uncomfortable
with those new definitions because hemp
is defined as not having anything over3
and now we'd have two just a state
unique definition of a regulated hemp
and so I think that goes too far and
certainly can undermine The credibility
of both cannabis and hemp okay thank you
you also signed up to speak is Kate fry
Futures good morning members of the
committee I'll be very brief um I just
want to uh first say I think this is a
well intended amendment I just think it
just doesn't get where we need to go I
think uh what I would like the committee
to do is consider the original bill
again that was something we were in
support of um I wanted to say that I
think we're getting confused by
conflating this with House Bill 1633 and
separate it but a representative pointed
out that I signed in on HB 1633 so I'm
even confused how these two relate to
one another so I understand the
committee's confusion
I just want to take you back to when
this original bill was introduced last
year as SP 180 and it was a Prohibition
on these products because we were
finding that there were these um illegal
products that were popping up
inconvenience stores gas stations what
have you many people and since those
retail stores are purchased by The
Liquor Commission the Assumption was
that these were legal and okay so our
intent with that it was just to prohibit
that it made it through the Senate it
made it through the house it passed um
oh I'm sorry it it was sent interim
study in the house Commerce Committee
and then it got attached to this other
Bill relating more to the study
committee of legalization so I really
just think we need to separate out um
the issues and right now we just have to
make sure this prohibition stays in
place so if we do nothing the
prohibition will end in October and what
we want to do is pass the original bill
so that these products will be remain
prohibited until we figure out how they
can be regulated as part of our
regulatory process which other states
have done who've moved in that direction
but I just would think it's more helpful
to think of these as two very separate
issues um so I would again Ask the
committee to go back to the original
Bill and pass the original Bill and look
at some things in the amendment I also
understand from The Liquor Commission
who' be responsible for this that there
are several issues with it I think they
signed in aose but I don't know if
they're um planning to speak but that
might be a helpful perspective as well
too thank you any
questions representative Murphy thank
you Mr chairman uh I'll ask the same
question I asked Mr Simon your original
testimony when it was first presented
was in support of the bill you do not
support the amendment you support
1633 1633 is a separate issue for us
futes would at best neutral if our
principles um regarding responsible
commercialization is adopted but that's
a separate issue completely we're
opposed to these very concerning we we
want these products off the shelves
immediately so but you didn't say to me
what was your opposition to the
amendment itself so I I do think it's
well intended but I just based on what
Mr Simon said I don't think it gets you
where it want you want to go with
regulating it yet and I also think my
understand as the Liquor Commission had
concerns about how this amendment was
written so it's regulation of it that
bothers you it's regulation I don't I
don't necessarily mind regulation down
alone I don't think this does that thank
you other
you no one else has signed up to testify
on this amendment does anyone else wish
to
testify seeing no one could I get the
blue sheet please u m while you're back
there
up thank you very
much the blue sheet in the back uh five
opposed and online there's 27 in support
20 opposed but again we don't know if
that's the underlying bill or this non-
gerain
amendment okay seeing no one else uh
signed up to testify I am going to close
the public hearing on um Amendment 2024
hyphen 1739 H to Senate Bill
505 uh that concludes our public
hearings for this morning and U we will
be um we're going to need a okay can we
come back at 11:30 yeah we we're going
to take a brief recess um and we'll be
back at 11:30 to open the executive
session uh on the noticed uh bills uh in
the calendar thank you
and
e
okay I'd like to call the executive
session to order uh we have a p uh Pro
complimented bills to go through that
we're going to try to get through this a
through the course of the day uh we'll
probably be breaking for lunch around
noon or shortly thereafter but we will
get through as many as we can leading up
to that point uh beginning with Senate
Bill 400 um representative
mlan thank you Mr chair
um Mr chair I'd like to um offer
Amendment uh
1830 and uh speak to the
amendment I'll second
that go go ahead representative mlan
yeah so I just um okay so during the uh
the the public hearing uh last week um
there was discussion about the fact that
there's there's this disparity if if the
patient is requesting the record or or
the patient's agent or or attorney is
requesting the record and I think you
know what basically came out of the
public hearing is that there really
isn't any significant difference in the
workflow um whether the person who's
processing the record receives it from
the patient or from the patient's
attorney it's basically uh the same
workflow so on the surface of it it
would you know seem fair to just say hey
let's just make it
$66.50 for everybody since the workflows
are essentially identical but the
problem is is that the the cost of of
going through and being able to get
those records is is not
$66.50 um and so if you basically make
it $6.50 across the board then the
third- party providers that are
basically doing the work they're just
going to I mean they're not in this for
charity they're just going to kind of
walk away and they're going to say yeah
this this is not a business model that
we want to support anymore and um we're
obvious obviously because of Hippo
there's nothing we can do about the
$6.50 so what I tried to do in the
amendment was kind of find my way uh to
some compromise you know speaking with
representative L she went through and
did some research looking at you know
how do they handle this in other states
and other states they have caps um for
the for the the patients attorneys that
are above the
$6.50 U but obviously not you know up to
infinity and beyond and so for example
something like Alaska would would cap it
about $75 and there were other uh states
that came in about1 but about $100 was
pretty much at the top end of of what I
was seeing so um I I went with a $100 in
this amendment based on that and um
given the fact that there's extra
Logistics involved with the paper copies
I made it
$150 um for paper copies I was pulled
aside uh just before um uh we came in
and saying hey the way that you have
written the amendment because you have
not changed the definition of requester
from when the original bill was written
that basically means that even the
patient now is not capped at $6.50 that
the patient is capped at $100 so it was
my understanding I had looked at that um
when I had put it into ol it was my
understanding that Hippa trumped um and
so that basically that that $100 would
only come into being um if those aspects
of HIPPA were rescinded um and that that
at least was my understanding um
obviously if that's not the case and we
can kind of discuss this we we'd have to
go back you know and do some follow-up
drafting on this um but that was my
understanding and I know that there are
some attorneys on the committee that we
could maybe kind of flush out and had
that as part of the discussion but
anyways that's that's kind of the meat
and potatoes of uh the amendment that
I'm offering and thank you Mr
discussion representative Nagel thank
you Mr chairman um I I'm I'm just to
reiterate what I've said before as long
as the attorneys are in this bill I'm
not supporting it at all I W to support
amendment I will not support the bill I
think they're two totally separate
things having reviewed documents of up
to 2500 pages in length from attorneys
that have to be copied by um Physicians
offices takes a lot of time that's also
my understanding in the near future
hippo requirements are going to change
that you have to be incredibly cautious
about going through the record and
deciding what you will and will not send
which means that it's not just hurling a
chart and pushing a button it's going to
be dramatically more complicated so um I
I think if you if you eliminate them I'd
support it if you leave them in I'm not
going to
representative Leon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
mlan for bringing the amendment um
looking at this and looking at the
understanding I thought that there was
an idea that um the committee probably
had some number that they wanted to
increase it to and so doing that work
and looking at what the cap would be on
a non-patient request um was why I was
providing the information and trying to
get to a number um frankly it there's
there's a couple things that bother me
about the medical records it's my record
and I think anybody should want my
record that I give permission to to get
my record should get it and I think the
fact that anybody's going through and
doing anything to my record before
releasing it to me I find absolutely
atrocious so the idea that there needs
to be work other than referencing it and
then doing the output to it um I I think
I I don't understand how there's an
expensive workflow because it's my my
record and I should have it um you know
further depending on how much time we
have if we decide not to exact this one
right away um there there's some talking
about how a medical patients medical
records are stored and available in an
electronic format they should be
provided in that format to the requester
um but if we if we don't end up
executing that one today I'll bring an
amendment or maybe just might even do it
on the floor if we do exec it so that it
provided in that format without being
turned into paper or into another less
usable format before because I've tried
to deal with documents where somebody
prints it scans it in an unfriendly way
and then gives me an electronic where
the utility has been massive massively
degraded um I know that there's some
concern about this being a fishing
Expedition but you know when you look at
it and when you're hiring an attorney
they're not going to be doing all of
this stuff um without you know you have
the argument about you know being able
to go and have it be cheap to get the
information and have ai do it but at
that point too they could just have an
individual provide that record um to me
to me really the only thing to enforce
whether or not doctors are following
clinical guidelines doing what they
should do is having that check on it and
um to me I just think we should have
access to our record so I appreciate
bringing the amendment hopefully
hopefully we'll be able to figure out
where we are on this um but if we're not
able to amend it I'm going to support
the underlying but I think I'll probably
support depending on where we are thank
you other discussion representative
Merchant thank you and also pres mlan
thank you for bringing forth the
amendment I think it goes in the right
direction
I have a concern because if you're a
trial lawyer or malpractice attorney you
take it on the case and make money on it
so I want to be sure we don't have an
indirect way that we're subsidizing that
business model by making it less costly
for them to obtain records in order to
make the business model more profitable
and I don't know where that fine line is
in there um but that's my concern is
that whether it's $100 $150 when you
think about about some of these
malpractice settlements they're in the
million sometimes so therefore if we're
trying to allow the attorneys the
opportunity to get a lot of records at
no cost or minimal cost are we doing two
things one are we going to increase the
possibility of malpractice because it's
easy to get the records a little cost to
them and at that point in time if they
have these large settlements why are we
taking the money from the from somebody
else to shift it over to somebody who's
making a money off from it so that's
kind of where I'm coming from I do want
to say what you did today is going that
direction but I don't know if this is
the answer to
it other discussion representative South
King thank you Mr chair um I also will
not be supporting the amendment or the
underlying Bill uh to me this looks like
price fixing um uh we're putting a cap
on what an industry can charge um I
think even just labor costs costs more
than what would be allowed I mean
nothing is $6 or $100 anymore people
make that in an hour so if you do even
just a little bit of Labor you're you're
already exceeding that never mind all
the the money that goes into storing and
that whole process and I also think
we're leg regulating what we don't
really understand um it was clear from
the public hearing day that there were a
lot of questions on how this like
industry even works and a lot of us were
confused by it and so the idea of like
regulating something we don't understand
I have a problem with and then last um
we're pushing the cost to those who do
not request their information so you
know you have millions of patients and a
subset of them are going to request
their information and if we don't uh if
if we don't charge them then the money
that the industry has to pay to give
them is going to be borne by everybody
else in their medical bills so I don't
like the idea of socializing the cost
I'd rather it be like look if you want
your if you want your records you have
to pay the cost and um there's also that
attorney thing that kind of is weird to
me as well so I I understand why they're
an issue and there's problems but I
don't think this is the
solution representative um
Nagel thank you Mr chairman I it would
be hypocritical for me to not say the
following but rep representative Le I
agree with everything you said about
this being the patients chart and I and
I think that it should be available to
patients
unredacted um at a low cost um but I but
I I come to an end when it comes to
attorneys requesting it for their issues
I will also say sorry that a lot of
times we get attorney requests for
disability um like um Social Security
Disability VC rehab things like that
where they're not making any money off
of that so it's almost like we have a
lot of different circumstances we're
dealing with here it's not the only
one represent robt did you have your
hand up a moment ago I'm sorry no
problem um I'm still sort of trying to
formulate my thoughts on this bill
because there are a lot of
contradictions in my mind uh I
absolutely agree that the patients
they're the patients records and the
patient ought to do what they want to do
with their records I'm kind of horrified
to find that there are aggregator I I
shouldn't say aggregators but they're
they're they're folks working under
contract to do the record review before
they're sent out uh because that was
just a New Concept to me although a
medical um organization should have the
right to contract with whoever they feel
does the best job of dealing with
whatever they're dealing with I get
that
um I'm still struggling with the
question that wasn't adequately answered
I don't think at the initial hearing
which is why doesn't the patient just
get the record and then hand it to the
attorney I get it that the attorney
needs the records to evaluate whether
they want to take the case or not
because although some cases are worth
millions of dollars not every case is
and you need if you're working on a
contingency basis you need to make an
appropriate evaluation about whether
this case is one you want to take or not
so there there's a need to be able to
get things at less
cost I'm not a medical malpractice trial
attorney so there are a lot of questions
that I have that I don't have answers to
so anybody who's making reference to the
attorneys in the room I got nothing for
you because my specialty was elder law
um and a few
divorces
um so there are a lot of equities
involved in this bill in all kinds of
different
directions um I fervently wish that the
bill had been sent to
Judiciary because the issues in the bill
are not really health issues except for
the protection of privacy which is
something that is just as much a concern
of the Judiciary Committee as it is of
us
um one part of my brain is saying
because there are all of these questions
interim study might be a viable
alternative I'm not entirely persuaded
that interim study in this committee is
going to clarify much uh which is a
long- winded way of saying having
listened to everybody and agreed with
practically everything that everybody
said I am completely in a quandry about
what I'm going to do about the
bill so I hope I hope that was really
helpful to everybody representative mlan
uh yeah so thank you Mr chair I mean I I
would be more than willing to to go back
and and kind of revisit maybe clarify
you know the federal versus State thing
re-evaluate the limits but I I guess I'm
just kind of looking to get a a straw
poll if you could Mr chair to kind of
figure out where we are is that worth
doing uh is it worth interim studying um
so I guess the question I would ask to
the committee is does this amendment
have any support and should it be looked
at further or or no so who would support
it I guess who's in favor of the
amendment sure representative Weber the
only other comment I would have based
solely on the construction on the
content in this amendment is that um the
argument was made to me and I think it's
probably a good one that if you're given
what was sent to us by the Senate if if
what you're trying to do is hit 150 as a
sweet spot you probably ought to write
the amendment as more but I certainly
obviously can't speak for what the
Senate will do about anything that we
send them so but but I I I appreciate
the
effort point of clarification to
representative McLean are you asking for
a St poll about the amendment or talking
about an option to El interim study um
right now I'm I'm yeah right now I'm
just looking you know on the amendment
if we say like it no I don't think that
the amendment even there's enough here
to even work on at this point so I can't
support it the interim study I think
would be separate discussion I just want
to know you know is there enough support
behind this amendment in any form or or
not and so then if that's the case I
would just withdraw the amendment so
that we could move on to another
discussion around value of interim study
or things of that nature so I guess
that's what I was looking for
representative
Merchant representative Lon um thank you
Mr chairman um I I just looking at this
my my question would be if there would
be if we knew who wasn't going to vote
for any version vote positively either
an not to pass or an not to pass pass as
amended if we knew who was going to be
either an interim study or an itl that
would guide us as to whether we're going
to work on an on an amendment we don't
need to clarify the difference between
interim study and itl at this point if
that's a reasonable straw poll well I
think you do
because I mean there just way too many
options so respectfully my my point is
whether or not we work on continuing to
amend the bill or if we get into motions
on in on on something other than an
amended or the underlying bill so if we
know that we don't have enough people
that would pass the bill or pass the
bill with any amendment that would be
gerain to this then we know that then
we're into a discussion of interim study
or itl okay said that way I I F now
following you okay so who would be
amendment just support some sort of
Passage um either this amendment or
ought to
pass is anybody accounting by the way no
okay
handsor you come um and we have more
than half of us that would be willing to
pass some form of this bill well
potentially is that oh is that I I guess
the question wasn't exactly clear um who
would be would be able to did you mind
if I phrase it um thank you who um sees
some way of getting either to ought to
pass or to pass is amended um on this
bill including including raising the cap
yes including raising the cap but some
way of getting to either a to pass or
ought to pass as amended 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 12 13 14 okay so now we just
need to figure out how those 14 go um I
guess should we start an auction process
who's over $100 for the for the
attorneys or people or I guess
maybe representative or
I think for speaking only for myself um
I think the number in an amendment that
I would support should be higher not
lower representative
Murphy thank you Mr chairman um I I
would vote for itl for both the bill and
for the amendment and the reason I say
that is that if you kept the bill I
would eliminate on Section a line 8
everything after the patient um the
patient's personal representative the
attorney etc etc um as far as I'm
concerned I agree with with
representative Leon the the record is
the patients right to have in any shape
or form they get it whether it's paper
whether it's electronic however they get
it it's their record when they go to a
physician for referral you want the
least amount of paper is possible
because the referring physician does not
want to read a whole lot of stuff so I
would eliminate the Bill entirely
because I think the patient gets the
patient record for free and they should
uh and anybody after that if they want
to re request a copy of the um the
record for whatever reason if they get
the consent of the patient which is done
now it's done at whatever the cost of
the going cost is you now I don't have
that right in my head but it should be
at a cost to the um the people that
requested but in in my mind the bill
goes nowhere and I don't care what
number you put on it what what you do it
Chang it what amend me you put forward
to my mind you know the patient's record
is the patient's property the patient
should have the right to it for free of
charge anybody else after that can get
the copy as at the consent of the
patient but they would pay the going
rate whatever that might be for the
institution to provide for the
information at no cost at I I shouldn't
say at a profit they should get the
record but not at a profit so you know
as far as I'm concerned that's why I
would itl this bill you Amendment
representative
Nel um if we were going to go that
direction of amending the bill I would
feel
strongly that we not have a cap but have
a sliding scale which I know
dramatically increases the complexity of
this bill which might make an interim
study make a lot more sense but I will
tell you you know I deal with a lot of
people with complex disabilities and
seeing a 2500 page chart to review is
not that unusual and that's a lot
different than copying 50 or 100 pages
so um I I think that if we're going to
go that way a simple Cap's not good
enough for
me representative uh kushman thank you
Mr chairman I um for all of the reasons
stated I will not support this bill um
pretty much in any form that I can
conceive it being brought forth now I
think I think um Dr NE representative
nle you had a very good point with the
FL sliding scale because playing you
know throwing out numbers and saying
well how about this how about that
that's very arbitrary and nothing
government does should ever be arbitrary
um so it sounds like this really needs
more study and um you know I agree some
patients are so medically complex and
have such a long history we're talking
you know tens of thousands of pages
potentially um from from especially if
it's one hospital system where they've
had all their care um so for all those
reasons I won't be supporting know at
least one of us has to leave at noon or
there abouts um so if you have a couple
of quick comments representative
merchant do you have something quick I I
basically my comment is that I would be
willing to support inum study I think
there's some merits here but as it's
written today and not getting all the
stakeholders together and trying to find
a path forward is premature
representative
Shapero yes thank you Mr chairman I'm
just wondering if um representative
Nagel could elaborate on what the
sliding scale would be based on um is it
the kind of case quick answer
but request for next week in exec we can
should we put in a schedule unbelievably
quick answer I would defer that to
people that know period I don't know I
don't maybe we maybe uh should we recess
and then come back at one and continue
this discussion would that be
appropriate why don't we do that okay
all right why don't we recess uh and
come back at one go to lunch and any
meetings we may have and we'll continue
you
to
e
I'd like to reconvene the executive
session and we were talking about sp400
before we broke at noon and there's been
more discussion since then
representative mlan uh you and I with
speaking earlier and you got any
thoughts yeah so uh thank you Mr chair
so I
mean I brought forth the amendment I I
thought it was an attempt to to strike a
fair balance but you know I'm obviously
reading the te leaves and I I don't
think it it's going to have the the
Firepower to kind of go through today so
I'm going to um I think there was some
discussion about inim study I'm going to
withdraw uh the motion if you withdraw
your second and then we can go on to
some subsequent discussion okay I I'll
withraw my a second
also um and again I've heard um I've
heard discussion of inim study U so I
for that matter I I guess I can make
that motion I'll move inim study do I
have a second
second uh and again um not to belabor it
but obviously there's a lot of concerns
about this bill it's it's it's
complicated for a whole bunch of
different reasons and this would be the
most at this point in time this would be
the most appropriate course of action um
any other thoughts or any other comments
I I share the thoughts with the chairman
at this point in time it's a complex
issue that I think needs to get resolved
but right now try to do it with our
committee and the amount of time we have
left to work through it logical things
is to do is pull us together again over
the summer through interim
study thank representative Nan um just
two items um Ben Brad actually informed
me that um what I proposed for this
fighting scale is actually the current
statute which I thought was interesting
but um I'm I'm all right with inim
study okay any other thoughts
representative
plazo thank you Mr chair I will vote
against interim study I think uh
patients own their record so they should
be able to get to it without uh paying
thousand of dollar even if they do it
through their uh
lawyer okay thank you Mr chair yes
clarification I don't think this impacts
the patient it's only people who are not
representative other
discussion St done okay the motion is
interim study on Senate Bill
400 I'll ask the clerk to call the roll
representative Leon no
representative kushman
yes cler votes
yes representative kofalt
yes representative mlan
yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative Nagel yes Representative
pelosof
no representative Weber
yes representative McKay yes
representative
rung
yes representative Canon
yes representative nut
upam representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant
yes representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer
yes representative tez
yes represent McDonald yes 18-2 motion
passes
um we could put that on consent good no
objection to consent okay right thank
you up okay uh next up is Senate Bill
402 um representative virgin I believe
the Amendments coming around to the
committee
e
if I may Mr chair sure basically I want
to say thank you to KB and Lon she
caught the uh drafting error we a motion
sorry motion thank you jump guns motion
to uh pass Amendment
1810 I have a
second representative Weber seconds
okaya
Merchant so in the draft of the first
time I made the amendment there was a
mistake because I was working off the
wrong version of the Senate bill that
was passed so I made the correction if
14 it just basically says that point
time vaccines licensed by the United
States Food and Drug Administration and
also recommended by the United States
Center for Disease Control and
prevention advisory committee on
immunization practices or the successor
organization that was what it should
have said but unfortunately the first
time I did it was the wrong version of
the Senate so I wanted to make the
correction I want to say thank you to tr
L for catching the A and then number two
one of the things I did hear from the
pharmacy Community was that on line 17
they wanted to be sure that it only
applies to those who administer the
vaccine um not to other technicians and
so forth that it it sort of implied but
they wanted to have it explicit which
made sense to me and then also on lines
30 on the back side they had to re
things
because by putting in the audition of
the um who ministers the vacines we had
to go through the process through make
it into instead of one two and three the
drafting attorney said it has to become
a b c and d why I don't know but that's
what they instructed me to do so it
basically takes the one turns it to a
forth so it's more of a nomeclature
or drafting process everything else
Remains the Same okay thank you any
other
discussion seeing any representative
representative nle did you have your
hand up I guess so I'm just curious why
do they need to have a minimum of
professional liability insurance now
that's in current law oh it is
discussion see actually no so we can be
quicker I don't need to okay seeing no
other discussion I'll ask the cl to call
all motion is ought to pass on Amendment
2024 D1 1810 H to Senate Bill
402 representative Lan yes
yes clerk votes yes representative
kofalt
yes representative mlan
yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missour
yes representative Nagel
yes Representative poosa
yes representative McKay
yes representative rung yes
representative Canon yes representative
n upam
yes representative
Shapiro
yes representative Merchant
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Palmer
yes represent tez
yes represent McDonald yes 19 to one the
amendment
passage representative merchant do you
want to make another motion yes I will
yes I'll make a motion to pass Senate
Bill 402 as amended
by Amendment 2024 1810 H second and
representative wber
seconds any other
discussion representative Lon um thank
you Mr chairman and thank you
representative Merchant for bringing the
amendment to clarify that and pull out
the different statutes um I I appreciate
me making it a lot clearer um I'm still
I it still bothers me to delegate the
selection of vaccines to other bodies on
doing this to that um CDC and asip and
so because of that I can't support the
the bill but I greatly appreciate you
making it so that we have stronger
language because most likely this
probably will be what becomes law so I
appreciate the Improvement however I
don't think that we should delegate our
job so thank
you other
discussion oh representative
Plaza thank you Mr chair I also cannot
support the the bill as amended uh
because it's relinquishing
responsibilities of New Hampshire
general court and gives it uh to uh
Federal bodies like CDC and FDA and uh
definitely I'm not happy how they um
doing current vaccination and responded
to pandemic and you know who else
unhappy with how they did it they
themselves uh unhappier so we are saying
that in this body we don't have uh
enough experience but CDC director
valinski said herself that there was
lack of stuff with adequate clinical
experience in CDC and that there were
some major problem flip
flopping uh uh they used testing
initially with that were faulty up to
33% error rate the the they were not
testing a sympatic people that they were
craning or detaining in cruise ships uh
so they was One Missed opportunity after
another and what's going on now did they
get better
so uh when we heard about
vaccination uh this covid vaccine uh uh
Dr Benjamin Chen recognized that uh
there are some cases of my carditis in
young males but how did vaccine get to
the heart it should stay in the muscle
tissue and for decades there were
protocols to for vaccines to stay in the
muscle tissue people were using
aspiration so to test that needle is not
in a blood vessel uh people were using
slow
injection to make sure that we don't
Rapture baby tissue and babies don't
experience mRNA in their hearts that are
making holes so what CDC recommends
currently if you go to and Google CDC
the pink book it's uh vaccine
preventable recommendations the have
chapter that say says inject vaccines
rapidly without expiration so those very
practices that for decades were used for
safe vaccine
Administration Federal bodies like CDC
tells us don't do it do it the other way
so I'm very uncomfortable with
us
uh moving our duties to CDC when when
CDC itself recognizes that there are
many missed opportunities and Mis
Administration thank you thank you other
discussion representative Merchant thank
you Mr chair I also want to say uh to
representative poo I do understand what
you're saying although this doesn't
speak to the merits of the vaccine talks
about who actually administer the
vaccine um and then number two if I
could repr Lon um right
now almost all the other Healthcare
Providers can get the vaccine and we're
basically saying with PR say can't so if
I go to NSE practitioner I can if I go
to an MD I can if I go to a PA I can I
mean I go on and on and on about all the
places the patients can go to me this is
a patient access issue it's allowing the
patient that get to the vaccines that
they would normally get someplace else
to help them with access to minimize the
barriers right now we know on primary
care it's a challenge to get in make an
office visit so if you want to get a
vaccine at that point in time this
provides greater opportunity greater
access for the patients so it doesn't
speak to the merits of the vaccine it
speaks to the access to the
patient representative Lon um thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for that
representative Merchant um I think we've
discussed before about how pharmacists
really could do a lot more than we
currently allow them under law I would
rather give them all of those Powers
together as opposed to picking out
different ones because the only way we
can get to practicing to the scope of
practice is by getting some of this
group's fa favorites here and some of
this group's favorites there so that we
can move on to a better
solution I concur with repon I would say
this right
now that's a longterm goal but right now
we have to sometimes take baby steps to
get there and at this point in time I
think it's a safe baby step for them to
take
this is not a mandate this is only an
opportunity this is a question about
patient access and I would love to work
with you on a bill to try to comp to try
to expand and make the access and use of
pharmacist broader to hopefully tax some
healthcare issues we have
today other
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
collector call of roll the motion is
ought to pass as amended on Senate Bill
402 representative Lon
no Representative kushman no lurk votes
no representative kofalt yes
representative
mlan
yes representative Seth King
no representative Missour
Nagel Representative poosa
no representative Weber yes
representative McKay
yes representative run yes
representative Canon yes representive
Nutter
upam representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes represent
Murphy
yes represent Palmer
14-6 motion passes yeah would have to go
on the regular calendar I would assume
okay okay next up is Senate Bill 411
representative Lon did you have a motion
uh yes I move out to pass do I have a
second second representative Weber
seconds would you like to speak to a
motion representative L uh yes thank you
very much Mr chairman um this addresses
an issue that is very important and has
hit many people in my in my town
including a mom who came and spoke with
us um this is a committee looking to see
what how we can make sure that we can
provide access to everybody and I think
that it makes sense to move forward see
what that committee comes up with and
then address those results after that
committee does its work good
representative Weber did you wish to
speak to you a second
or no thanks I think that that took care
of it it's it's an important issue it's
it's one that I think we really ought to
work on okay thank you other discussion
representative plazo uh thank you Mr
chair I will be voting against it I
agree that it's an important uh issue uh
but uh
establishing yet another committee and
uh uh from testimonies uh it feels like
uh people already pushing to one certain
um decision and uh it's like U uh I feel
like it's already covered only now if
State wants those services are uh
delivered state state pays for them but
now uh the solution offer is to
push um price
um Insurance Company to pay for it so
it's like unfunded mandate in my view uh
so so uh I just uh think that the way it
is might be more fair than than what uh
we are trying to achieve with this
Bill thank you other disc representative
Missour yeah thank you um I am going to
be voting against this as well not
because I'm against studying Mental
Health Services because of what I heard
in the hearings um that um the New
Hampshire instit Insurance Institute
said a work group was already formed to
address like the billing codes issue um
and so it sounds like they have a they
have a group form to address all the
concerns that came about as a result of
this bill and also it sounds like
there's a be Behavioral Health crisis
committee
that I feel that a lot of this can get
um put into two instead of another
separate committee um so just to uh
clarify though I'm not
against um doing this kind of thing it's
just it sound to me like this is
somewhat redundant so that's why I'm
voting against it okay thank you
representative Shapiro thank you Mr
chairman so I worked at a community
mental health center from 1995 to 2005
so that was a long time ago and this was
this was an issue then that um families
who came in with um children with
significant mental health needs if they
had Medicaid they got all kinds of
wraparound Services because those were
clearly reimbursed um but ironically if
they had private insurance um those same
kinds of services which would be like
case management or um
family support workers who went into the
family to help with parenting those um
Services were not clearly reimbursed so
here we are 25 years later with the same
issue and what I heard at the hearing
was that it is clear now that those
private insurers should be paying for
those services and do pay for those
Services because that's parody but but
it
but but the systems in place are not
working so it becomes incredibly
difficult to actually know the right
codes or
um to write um pre to write
pre-authorizations to get those services
so I think this is something that's been
in the works for decades and if you have
a severely mentally ill child with all
kinds of behavior issues that you're
struggling to keep in your home this is
an incredibly important issue and I
think
um you know once again I don't know that
a study committee will finally resolve
it but I think we should be doing
everything we can to resolve it so I
will vote for
this okay other discussion
representative Merchant thank you Mr
chair I concur with repr sharo um mental
health is a real issue for us in the
state and we're vastly under
um servicing it resourcing it I think
it's time for us to do something about
discussion okay seeing none motion is
out to pass on Senate Bill uh
411 I'll ask the collector call the all
representative Lan yes representative
kushman
uh can you tell me the motion again
sorry a motion is off to pass
no clerk votes no Representative kofalt
no represent mlan
no representative Seth King
yes representative Missour
no representative Nagel
yes Representative poov
no representative Weber
yes representative K yes representative
rung yes
representative Canon yes representative
nut upam
yes representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant
yes representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes representative
tez
yes and representative McDonald
yes 14 to six motion
passes okay again regular calendar give
them the split so a Minority Report um I
don't know will there be a Minority
Report
no does anybody want to do Minority
Report on
that I can CL if somebody helps me all
right I will I will like okay so you
will do the Minority
Report and and there's no session next
week so we're not under a strict
deadline but obviously I can get them in
the next M Dyer the next day or so okay
for these reports or do you need them
today
okay yeah no that's a little too
open-ended probably do them tonight
because there's 112 bills that still
need to be reported out and given that
there's going to be a lot of work typing
this up so I'd suggest people get them
in by tomorrow so do it tonight that' be
great yeah thank you if you could do
that that includes me too so
okay uh moving on uh Senate Bill 412 FN
representative kushman do you have a
motion yes I move a to pass on Senate
Bill 412
FN representative Missour seconds
representative kushman do you want to
speak to your motion yes thank you um so
this bill was pretty straightforward we
are um opening up temporarily the
moratorium on um existing long-term care
beds for a pediatric Intermediate Care
Facility um we have some resident well
would be residents who are in need of
those beds so we're going to open it up
for
them and I do just want to mention
that I can't I can't make this motion
without saying something about the
moratorium in general that it's there to
protect a um
funding organized funding mechanism that
is not sustainable and we end up with
shortages like this that end up driving
up health care costs and this is a
short-term solution it's a Band-Aid and
we keep putting Band-Aids on it and I
hope that eventually uh we find a way to
get rid of this moratorium and and allow
the uh free market to run things in the
healthcare industry thank you thank you
other
discussion saying on okay thank you all
right motion is ought to pass on Senate
Bill 412 refm I'll ask the clerk to call
the all representative L yes
representative kushman yes cler votes
yes representative kofalt yes
representative mlan yes representative
King representative Missour yes
representative
Nagel representative poo
yes representative Weber yes
representative M yes representative rung
yes representative Canon
yes representative Nutter upam
yes representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant
yes representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes representative
tez yes and represent McDonald
yes
190 to one
any any objection to
consent okay put then the consent
calendar okay moving on next up is
Senate Bill 124 four excuse me 49- FN um
Mr chairman I just literally within the
last 30 seconds receive my Amendment
from OS so I'm going to send it up to
get printed um if we want to move to the
next and we'll gather it I may have two
to send I'll send it to you this off yes
so yes um okay um 458 I I think we're
waiting on something on that also so
let's go to um
um
scrambling um I would um like to move
Amendment
1798 we already have that do we yes I I
I I put it on everybody's desk uh this
it okay you made a motion to about the
pass on that Amendment yeah is there a
seconds do people need a chance to look
this is I'll speak whenever had a chance
You' like to speak to your motion
representative McLean okay if everybody
um SP 461
um is is is another bill that that's
looking uh to uh have the state begin uh
the process of of gathering some
statistics around abortion um and and
Reporting those statistics so we we we
heard in in testimony that there are
currently
47 uh of the 50 states that that gather
and and provide information um around
abortion and I I think this is one area
where in concept no matter which side of
the abortion issue you stand on and and
it's obviously a very heated issue um
there there is a consensus that
Gathering some of these statistics would
be a good thing and that's why very
pro-choice States like California and
New York do that you know and um the the
goal is to be able to understand the
drive behind unwanted a pregnancy to to
look at you know what are the clinical
developments and things of that nature
and you know I I went in online just to
kind of look at you know how is this
information used and was reading a whole
bunch of different papers where they're
kind of drawing on this information so I
think the information has value um of
course the flying the ointment as as we
heard uh during the public hearing every
time I have representative Kirk come
before me and talk about privacy
concerns uh my antenna goes up because
you know I I share his concerns those of
you who don't know representative Kirk
and I know representative Weber
representative McKay who've been here a
while you you go back and you remember
the real ID debates and you know you'll
remember the Constitution amendment of
2018 term after term after term so there
there's nobody in whom I put more faith
that there's concerns around privacy
than than representative Kirk and so um
so what this amendment is doing is it's
trying to get at uh the statistics that
I think everybody thinks are valuable um
while being able to preserve um the the
the privacy of the woman and and
ensuring that that information is not
weaponized in any way so following the
the public hearing I went back to you
know representative Kirk a former
representative Kirk sorry and I just
said could you you know work on the
language around an amendment and so he
did that and that what you see reflected
here in front of you really is the bulk
of his work added to that um there were
some concerns you know from
representative Merchant who said you
know probably the the cleanest way to go
at this thing is to just have a fullon
optt out option for the woman to say you
know what I'm just not going to
participate in in the data Gathering
scheme so we can put all these
Protections in place but the ultimate
you know Adam Bomb at the end of the day
is giving um the woman the the option to
just completely opt out allog together I
just don't want to have any of my
information go into this and so I think
that goes far and above
what these other states are doing
because when I went in and I was reading
the papers that they're drafting you
know from this data they're talking
about demographic statistics they're
talking about causation and when we look
at the
information that we are gathering um in
this bill this is very vanilla you know
compared to what I was reading um in in
in the reports and the studies that have
drawn on the data from other states I
think this is really very vanilla so
part of me says you know is this going
to be a lot of a lot of benefit but I
think what it does is it is at least
goes in it kind of sets the framework
where we're Gathering some very vanilla
statistics and it's also setting up um
an appropriation and this is something
again coming from former representative
Kirk not for me I don't want to take
false credit where he's setting up an
approp ration to the Department of the
sum of $1 to hire such personnel and
implements a secure computer facility
you know with the act so I can we afford
that in a non-budget year to appropriate
that much
money well you know that's having never
served in finance but he cheered Finance
so I'll I'll defer to him but I think
what what it does is it kind of sets up
that architecture so I think on balance
if if you look at it um it's going
nothing in the paragraph so go back on
to um the the first page line six
nothing in paragraph two shall be
construed as requiring or permitting um
so he was very clear we want to put that
in um and we put uh the obviously the
medical facility um is still being
captured um because that has to go
obviously to DHS where where the
information is going to but the
amendment is very clear that even though
the medical facility is being in the
data that is being reported when the
report comes back to the general court
that the the even the medical facility
is not going to be listed in there so
that's making it further still to kind
of get into to geographical area
um the medical facility shall not report
either the name of the healthc care
provider performs the abortions or the
number of peror abortions performed by
any individual health care provider
again so that's making sure that we're
not going back and weaponizing against
the providers who who provide this
service um and then um and then not
withstanding the big thing is the
addition the whole addition of section
four basically comes out of the
discussion with representative Merchant
let's just give the woman you know an
opportunity to opt out if she's not
comfortable if she feels that she's in a
rural area where it may be easy to ident
ify hey this is a small town she can
just opt out the only thing that the
amendment does do it says it it it will
report just generically how many women
chose to opt out so um but it's not
tying that back to any individual at all
so I think you know from the input of
these other folks it's again it's not a
ton of information being gathered it's
very vanilla but it allows us to
establish the infrastructure with very
vanilla information with a lot of
Protections in place and remember 47
other states do this including prolife
States because they see value in in the
information so um I hope you consider it
I hope you'll support it and that's kind
of where I'm at thank you representative
Palmer thank you Mr chair and thank you
for the amendment I mean this
definitely improves it in my eye um
and because the opt out covers an awful
lot of things the only thing I wondered
is leaving in the state of residence of
the pregnant patient I could sort of see
where we'd want to know how many of
these people are actually New Hampshire
residents but having just listened on
the way into the um fact that there was
a woman who went to Colorado to have an
abortion and now the state of Texas is
trying to extract information from
Colorado about this abortion so they can
charge the providers and the woman um
and Colorado has a shield law and we
don't and so I just wonder
if you know the opt out presumably that
person would opt out of providing the
information but I'm just a little bit
uncomfortable with
that representative
Weber thank you very much Mr chairman
and thank you for all the work that you
put in on this and I I certainly
recognize that the amendment goes away
towards um answering some of the privacy
issues that said um the issues that I
still have here are the issue raised by
representative Palmer about the state
that the other that the woman may have
come from um the gestational periods are
divided in a way that doesn't seem to me
to make sense with the way these kinds
of proced procedures are handled because
generally speaking medication abortion
goes up to 11 weeks and um after that
they're not appropriate it needs to be
um a surgical abortion and this puts
that time
frame I'm sorry that puts that time
frame precisely in the middle of one of
these divisions which doesn't seem
sensible to me um
the appropriation of a dollar's cost
does not answer the problem that the
department will have of having to
organize a way to uh address these
statistics nor does it um help with the
burden on the facilities that have to do
the
reporting
um I'm not sure how this protects
somebody who might be a single provider
whose uh statistics might not be
aggregated as they would in in a large
scale
facility um and and finally um the the
issue that I see is if we are trying to
collect Val valuable and valid
statistical
data uh the protections that we've put
on to protect privacy all of which I'm
in favor of uh make the the data all but
useless in terms of understanding what's
going on um I will vote for the
amendment because I think it's
considerably better than the original
bill but I just want to say that my vote
for the amendment is conditioned on the
fact that I'm incredibly offended at how
this bill came to us it was a bill that
was about something completely different
and it was commandeered in the Senate
and changed into something that it
wasn't so my name under our rules is on
the bill that I cannot support and will
not support and would never have it in a
million years
introduced um which is a fla and or
rules that I understand we can't deal
with here uh but I I ultimately think
that our law is correct the way it is
and I'm going to vote against the
bill representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for that input
representative Weber I hope that I'm not
in the same boat about having a bill
hijacked by the other body to be
something that I can't support we'll see
how today shakes out um looking at some
of these points that been raised um my
question would be if changing the state
of residence of the P pregnant patient
to um whether the the pregnant patient
is a resident of New Hampshire or not um
to separate the sections into before 6 6
to 15 15 to 20 uh 20 to 24 and after 24
weeks would deal with that um the
concern or if it should be a different
date to do that uh because if we're
looking at how we would be impacted
should somebody do the unthinkable and
look at Federal legislation uh because
this is a state issue not a federal
issue uh that that would then give us
information about how much that would
impact our state so that we can
appropriately respond to our um to our
federal representatives and then
additionally um I do want to point out
that those who opt out the fact that
they've opted out um so we essentially
get a null value but there was an
abortion performed that does not
invalidate all the numbers it just means
that some of it doesn't provide any of
this information that is valuable to
groups um such as that is valuable
information and then finally in order to
deal with the concern about medical
facilities and um even potentially the
date which had been a problem U been
raised because of the idea of uh geoca
although I don't think there's enough in
this to do this would changing it to the
month in which the abortion was
performed allow us to at least have some
seasonal data so that if we find out
that there's some month in which there's
a huge number of abortions perhaps there
should be some messaging around safe sex
during whichever time period that is
that may make sense as a good policy
position um and just so that we can have
some information on that so as as far as
that goes would that actually gain more
support or those of you who are against
the bill against the bill even with
those
changes representative Weber speaking
only for myself um I I think that that
definitely helps with the Privacy issue
but I think it makes the data collected
more less useful uh so I'm I'm going to
vote no in any case
so representative McLean U yeah thank
you uh Mr chair so yeah I mean and I
understand the
the comment that is the data so vanilla
that it's not useful and like I said
when I went online and I'm reading the
kinds of studies and the things that
they're doing with the data I can kind
of see you know why you would would say
that but I think we're at a point right
now where the privacy concerns are
trumping everything and so we're we're
we're coming in intentionally vanilla to
prove out the system which is why at
this point any
that I could do you wanted to go to
month you wanted to go to just a
resident of New Hampshire anything that
I could do because right now privacy
concerns trumpet I'll do whatever I have
to do to kind of address those concerns
just to kind of establish the
infrastructure prove out the
infrastructure and then come back and
revisit um but obviously I mean if if
it's a hard no I mean I we'll just kind
of go to it today um but just I'm just
just kind of throwing it out there it's
intentionally vanilla for a reason so
thank you Mr chair other discussion
representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair and also
thank you represent clean for uh
bringing forth the amendment and
definitely listening to my concern about
the patient ability to opt out I think
it's fundamental to uh our right here in
the state of New Hampshire to uh
minimize any information we're sharing
and our ability to protect that
information at the same time I do have
concerns regard to some of the Phi one
of the things that I saw in here which
was not really spoke to is under line 18
any prescriptions it doesn't say what
information on the prescription is going
to be obtained so that's going to be
problematic because a lot of times you
can have Phi information etc etc um
that's really concerning again back to
privacy when you look at lines 16 and 17
I think the critical point if I
understand it correctly is that most of
the time if you have a medical or
prescription abortion it's going to be
up until the age of 11 sorry age 11 11
weeks so therefore I think it's an
actual cut off when you start looking at
16 to 15 that's going to be problematic
because you can't separate surgical from
medication one when I look at also the
commissioner reports and what we can
release it depends upon the commissioner
what's out there it doesn't really say
the commissioner can only release
aggregated data um there's really
nothing in there says that
deems useful if you look at line 24 as
useful and that's concerning because if
you have a change with a commissioner
that philosophy can change vers it's
saying it can only release aggregated
data
period um if you also look at the type
of medical facility my concern at that
point in time is that when you have
small communities that have a hospital
or you have a certain area I think it's
better to talk about it at that point in
time is what county is load loated in if
it's in County CFT inference Sal County
something like that versus the actual
type of facility so those are the things
I have concern on I also pick up in the
comment that representative um Weber
talked about and also our chair I don't
think a dollar is going to go very far
to implement this I think we're going to
ask the Department of Health Human
Services to take on a burden and not
fund it appropriately again it's
unfunded mandate placed upon another
agency that we're not appropriately
funding that's my
concerns representative mlan uh thank
you chair so again um those
are valid points representative Merchant
especially the dollar I I'd be more than
happy to move the date out of year
um and and to work on it to kind of go
to those concerns but again it's
just I just if that's going to be what's
necessary to win support obviously I do
that if not I mean I think we'll kind of
go with where we are but but I mean if
if if if you think that those things
would help bridge the gap then I would
be more than happy you know to kind of
hold off move it out of year with the
implementation so that we can get
through another budget cycle and kind of
bring some of these in so I'm I'm I'm
more than open to that if you think that
that's basically what would allow you to
get across the bridge representative
Seth King and then representative Leon
thank you Mr chair I'm a hard no on both
the amendment and the underlying Bill
I'd like to Echo what representative
Weber said earlier I don't like the fact
that this bill uh was sponsored by a
bunch of people and it wasn't just a a
minor change and minor difference in the
bill uh that happens to sponsors all the
time but to completely just throw in the
garbage the original Bill and come up
with something that has totally
different intent totally different
meaning that doesn't seem very right to
me but even if you are going to do that
there should have at least been one
sender to come and speak in favor of
that they couldn't even they couldn't
even muster one sender to come and speak
in favor of their own bill uh I didn't
think that was very cool there was only
one person to speak in favor of it and
and there was one moment in which he
said all these other states take this
information but New Hampshire just says
does not report and I thought to myself
that's awesome I wish we did that for a
lot of things New Hampshire just does
not report so that's just my attitude
it's it's you know and I there was a
bill uh similar that we we uh we did in
in our committee uh recently that um
uh it was the same thing I just feel
like look it's legal if you don't like
it work to change it but these sorts of
bureaucratic things that were just going
to muck up the gears I mean that's not
going to change anybody's opinion it's
just going to waste money we've got all
the other states that we can look at for
reference if we want to um and the
battle for whether it should be legal or
not can be fought elsewhere it shouldn't
be fought in the bureau y so that's what
I'm a hard know thanks representative L
and then representative pimer um thank
you Mr chairman um I've been subbing and
finance so I don't have a ton of
experience but I've had a little bit of
trial by fire now uh there's quite a
number of bills where there is $1
appropriated um there's many where it
does begin at the beginning of the next
budget cycle so it would be very much in
it would conform very much with a lot of
other bills that they are seeing in
finance if it was $1 and if it started
July 1st 2025 because there's no
positions created so because there and
that would be out of our scope to create
those positions but um if those
positions were if there with no
positions created that would be going
into the budget next budget cycle
request and by having it there that
would be something that they are already
looking to do within that whole
framework um and then just looking to
the the issue about nobody coming in to
support it I'm sure you've seen me
running back and forth between here and
um at least two committees over in the
other body um the Judiciary Committee
and health and human services are
meeting at the same time as us um so
it's very hard especially for those
chairs to make it over here so it's uh
one of one of the unfortunate features
of our scheduling representative Palmer
okay any other discussion representative
Shapero yes thank you Mr chairman I I
really appreciate the effort to um
however you put this make it more
vanilla or protect um you know protect
privacy and I'm particularly
appreciative of lines 21 lines 22 where
it says um basically that the medical
facilities shall not report the name of
the provider or how many abortions
they've provided because I think um
that's a very real danger for providers
and that's a little bit of protection
but um so I will vote for the amendment
but I won't vote for the bill and my
reasoning is really that um this is a
time of such flux and change which comes
along with as much as you said you don't
want something that can be weaponized I
think in this in this moment in history
it's very difficult to find anything
um I I'm just concerned about doing
anything that will
um add for me I'm I'm very hesitant to
do anything that may um add to further
restrictions to restrict abortion and I
I I I I know this people talk about
public health um but as you know often
we have the text of the bill and then we
have the subtext and it's hard for me to
feel that this isn't being pushed
because um of an agenda and I'm not I'm
not saying this about any particular
person but in to eventually restrict
abortion and that's not something I want
to participate in representative Bill
King thank you Mr chairman and um thank
you uh representative uh mlan for uh the
work that you put into this I on the
surface I support this bill um but I'm
not going to vote for it and a lot of
the chatter that's been going on um not
chatter but uh the discussion that's
been going on um has has pushed me in
that direction
I this is a bill that it's the second
time I've seen this I think the other
one was about two years ago and it IT
addresses a problem that we have when
when abortion is brought up and that
is how many abortions are done after 24
weeks
how many abortions are done after 15
weeks nobody knows nobody has any data
and then and we're going to see it in
the next few months we're going to see
plenty of abortion commercials that flat
out tell lies and the reason why they
can lie is because there's no data to
support the lie or to support the truth
and so that's why I think we really need
to have this data I just don't think
this bill and quite honestly I don't
really like the fact that they took a
bill that was addressing something else
and then turned it into something else
and um so for that reason I'm not going
to vote for this bill but I and um in
support of what uh representative mlan
has done I'm going to I'm going to vote
for the
discussion seeing none okay I'll ask
clct call a roll motion is out to pass
on two Amendment 2024
d7908 to Senate Bill
461 Mr clerk representative
land yes representative kushman
yes clerk votes yes representative
kofalt yes representative mlan
yes representative Seth King no
represent Missour yes represent Nagel
yes representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes representative
R yes representative Canon
yes representative nut upam
represent Merchant
yes representative Murphy
no representative Palmer
yes representative TZ
yes uh 15 to five motion passes
representative McLean do you want to
make another motion I'll make a motion
ought to pass as amended is there a
second representative Coachman
seconds you any other discussion on on
this issue we cover I think we're all
set yeah okay I seeing no other
discussion I want the clerk is ready
representative representative Weber was
moving a microphone I I thought she was
no representative Leon
yes representative kushman yes clerk
votes no representative kofalt
yes representative Seth King
no representative Missour
representative Weber
no representative rung no representative
Canon
no oh can you repeat that
fading represent Shapiro
no representative Merchant
no representative Murphy no
no representative Palmer no
Representative tez
no and represent McDonald yes 7 to13
motion fails do I have another motion
represented of
Weber I would move itl is there a second
representative Canon
seconds any discussion representative
Weber I don't think it's necessary at
this point I think we've all made our
points and I thank you all for the
discussion okay when the clerk is ready
I'll ask him to call the rooll motion is
461 representative Lon
no Representative kushman no
clerk votes yes Representative kofalt no
Representative mlan
no representative Seth King
yes representative Missour
represent McKay
yes represent Vang yes representive
Canon
yes representative nut
upam representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Palmer yes
representative TZ yes and representative
uh
13-7 motion
passes okay motion P itl passes okay I'm
assuming that will be on the regular
calendar I think so I think so
representative L on uh Mr chairman can
we actually put Senate Bill 411 on the
regular calendar inide of the
consent I just i' like to have it on
there in case the family wants in case
any of the family is impacted want to
see that pass okay that's that's fine
any objection to that I'm sorry which
one was it uh Senate Bill
itar it was 14 report oh there sorry
then I was 14 to six okay there I
certainly concurred for the regular
calendar I I marked the wrong box so
thank you representative Paz off's doing
a Minority Report with some assistance
on PO level I I'll do a Minority Report
on 461 sir yes okay and that will be
with your Amendment
yeah the competing ought to pass with
amendment
yes's
that can we do I
don't I don't okay we have received the
amendment on 419 FN so we'll go back to
that
direction so I won't get into the
details but I'll just give you that
first bite as this passes around this is
language um that came um from the
department and from Michael Hol to make
sure that the language was something
that would be um a little bit more
appropriate to implement uh or a little
bit more effective to implement and to
not get into privacy issues so I'll let
everybody actually read it before I say
more but I figured I'd just give that
um yes this this one here I think was
passed out before I actually have
another amendment Beyond this but this
is sort of the meat of it and the rest
is uh the potatoes and
gravy so is there to be another
amendment after this one um yes there is
I don't know if you want me to hand that
if we just wanted to look at this and
see if we wanted it and then go to the
next I'm very uncomfortable voting on
anything without knowing everything
that's in the package okay I and that
would be really I can do that the other
Amendment does not touch any of the
language that is in this the other
Amendment adds House Bill 1231 which is
the hom grow statute because um
that because uh that is something that
would be very necessary to protect
patients should this become something
that needs to be done through Pharmacy
and if the alternative treatment centers
are shut down if there's a change from
the FDA thank you so if it's okay to
wait on that one I just figured i' Focus
happy to wait on it being assured that
it's completely different yes it's it's
not even exactly the same and completely
different it's completely different so
um so thank you yes this is the one that
um we that I believe had been passed out
I think it was either at the hearing or
soon after that you want to make a
motion oh yes I'd like to make a motion
2024-25 I'll second that and
representative McLean seconds I proceed
reprentative L thank you um so this
amendment is drafted so that there is
this is going to back to that privacy
issue that we were just talking about on
the abortion statistics and about the
medical providers the other one would
have had a lot of information that had
to do with specific operations of those
involved in the therapeutic cannabis
program being reported this then makes
it so that instead of giving those
details of the reports it talks about
the number of alter alternative
treatment center plans of Correction to
address the areas of non-compliance the
number of hearings held the number of
statements of finding that were issued
when as a result of an inspection
complainer monitoring the department
determines that the ATC is in violation
of are not in compliance with any of
those um and the number of
Investigations as opposed to giving
details about which ATC is involved um I
I believe that um this is a more
appropriate level of transparency should
there be findings of problems then we
have other issues to deal with and given
that there's three ATC
um that's something that we can address
but I don't think that um airing
inspection results or anything else like
that publicly um and things that are
available under public records requests
makes much sense especially given the uh
delicate dance between federal and state
laws around this so I I hope we can
adopt this
amendment representative
Shapero thank you Mr chairman maybe I'm
just being thick but I I I'm
where specifically are the differences
between the amendment and the bill let
me pull it up I know it's the same
section so I will pull up the actual
bill so I can tell you the difference I
it and I was looking to pull that up
myself so not a problem I do know that
um let's
see so on uh J um which is line 21 of of
this in that we can see what the
amendment says but the bill as it came
to us says the statements of finding
that were issued when as a result of any
inspection complaint or monitoring the
department determines that the ATC is in
violation so ours would have this
amendment would say the number of
statements of finding that were issued
as opposed to publishing these
statements of finding um then in k um
our Amendment says the number of ATC
plans of Correction while um the bill as
it came to us says the ATC plans of
Correction so the actual plans and
details um so those are the two changes
thank
you representative
Weber so um are am I right in thinking
that uh the findings themselves and the
plan of Corrections are already public
documents um no I don't I don't believe
that they're currently public documents
okay I guess I'm not sure but I'm not
sure how having the commissioner's data
report including that data makes
sense okay why you have information on
that if we could pull somebody Abby
Rogers from the Department is here and
may be able to answer
you hi Abby Rogers legislatively aison
for the division of Public Health
Services um I actually covered this bill
for Mr H because he's out um on leave
and my understanding is uh there are
postings in the atc's public postings of
information as well as as uh you know
the information is is available through
a right to no request but it is publicly
available at the atcs it's my
understanding so follow up so my
followup is that they're already
available I see no reason to put anybody
through the um extra work of assembling
them again I think that the amendment
makes sense thank you other discussion
saying none
okay all right the motion is ought to
pass on 2024
d532 H to Senate Bill 419 FN I'll ask
RO
second represent
yes representative kushman yes clerk
votes yes
represent representative kofalt yes
representative mlan yes representative
Seth King
no representative Missour
yes representative Nagel yes
representative pelov
yes I'm sorry can you repeat that uh yes
yes representative Weber
yes representative McKay
yes representative run
yes representative Canon
yes representative Nutter upam yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant
yes representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes representative
TZ
yes representative McDonald yes 19 to
passes and sorry I should have counted
um this amendment is um verbatim coming
house so I'll move Amendment 24-1 1846 H
to Senate Bill
419 do I have a second representative
kushman
seconds okay um and speaking to this um
we now see that the um that there's a
very very high likelihood that cannabis
is and I didn't actually intend the joke
that time usually I
do um there the the likelihood is very
high that um I'm not going to be able to
stop so I'm just going to keep keep I
was going to make another I'm not that
punny um so there's a this will likely
be rescheduled from schedule one to
schedule 3 uh that is great because now
there can be research done into all
these medical uses but this is going to
be highly problematic because schedule
three drugs are dispensed through phes
generally schedule three drugs are done
through FDA approval which are generally
not for plants generally they are for
for um drugs or for biologics they are
not really prepared to handle any of
this um if we end up into the Quagmire
of how they Square class three um
scheduling of cannabis with continued
access to therapeutic cannabis it
becomes very very critical that patients
will have some way to access it and this
isn't an area where we would be an
island of prohibition with other states
around us
there's a decent chance that other
states won't be able to deal with this
either and this could be a very
significant um issue going on so by
allow permitting homerow um home
cultivation for therapeutic cannabis for
patients we won't interrupt that use of
cannabis for patients who otherwise may
be on opioids or other more harmful
drugs um so I mean it may seem like I'm
in a Christmas tree mode and uh feeling
with some of what I've said today I
think that this is absolutely critical
to make sure that patients are able to
continue to access cannabis if um if the
if the declassification of cannabis
market representative
Weber so what I'm trying to figure out
is uh you know I I was in support of
this when it went through the house um
I'm assuming that you without knowing
that you may have um attached this
because the Senate did something
different with it is that correct um I
believe that it had a report of interim
study um I'm not sure if it actually
went to the floor so I will find that
right now but I know that at least
coming out of committee it had interim
study and I did get a message today that
um at least one Judiciary member is
absolutely adamant that hom grow not um
move forward at least on the
recreational
and I will get that on there with that
information for which I thank you I
here's here's my concern I'm absolutely
in support of this for all of the
reasons that representative leyon has
just stated uh but we know what the POS
Senate position is likely to be and I am
not a
fan of adding things to other things and
confusing the issue it seems to me that
we had a fairly good bill um that we all
agreed on or most of us agreed on not
all of us um and that seems to me to be
good policy and
putting that bill in a position where
the good policy that we enact there is
very likely to Simply die because they
don't agree with the policy they've
already disagreed with doesn't seem to
me to be like a helpful thing to do so
uh speaking solely for myself although I
support the content entirely I don't
think I can vote for putting it on a
different
bill but I'm I'm willing to be persuaded
if somebody has a really good reason but
representative Nel I I just have a
question I mean I'm as a neop fight um
this seems very non- gerine to me what
what do does that mean anything
yeah the answer is that under our rules
um a gerine Amendment either has to be
Germain to the subject matter or it has
to be something that the house already
passed and it is the position of the
house so under our rules it is gerine
even though that word will make your
brain bounce in terms of this in terms
of this um
and it is another one of those practices
that the Senate attaches things to our
bills so we have made sure that we can
attach things to their bills I don't
think it's productive in either case um
I agree H just like I don't think it's
fair to keep people you know if somebody
wants to change a bill completely let
people take their name off it but um I I
I don't see the H that in this case the
tactic is useful it is useful in some
cases so am I allowed to say one other
thing sure go ahead I've never supported
this and I'm not going to
know representative Leon did you want to
um I I'll let others speak I represent
representative chapero and then
representative kushman ju just following
up thank you Mr chairman just following
up on representative Weber's comments I
I would ask representative Leon if you
have any indication that this will get a
better reception in the full Senate this
time um so thank you for that question
um when they were deal with this the
ruling coming out of the um coming out
of the federal government about the
declassification had not come out yet um
I know that they are just as busy with
as many topics as we are um and the idea
of having that knowledge about that de
declassification and the implications of
it um be something that is front and
center for them I don't think is
happening because Health and Human
Services in the Senate usually isn't the
one that deals with cannabis at least
last year all of that was in Senate
Judiciary this time that went to Senate
Health and Human Services so they have
less experience in that field and
um and there's I mean there's a chance
that the that their floor will do
something differently because um it was
a 3-2 vote in committee for interim
study um there's a decent chance that it
actually especi that especially if it
comes to their attention because we're
doing this um there's a very good chance
that they may change their mind on the
floor um so we have that possibility and
that change if there are people that
support one and then the other we could
always have the Blended of these two as
one of the positions and then the other
house position could be with only the
adopted representative Coachman did I
just ask the point of clarification sure
the house can't have two positions the
house will either vote one way or the
other I'm sorry the committee because we
have a minority and a major majority
when this bill came when 1231 came
through initially it was 154 on the
regular calendar so this isn't going to
be a consent calendar anyways
representative kosman thank you Mr
chairman um I just want to um voice my
support for this amendment um I'd like
that second bite at the Apple with the
new information coming down from the
federal government and um I would like
to hope that the Senate will reconsider
their position um since it well
especially it was only the committee not
the full um Senate who's had their vote
and I mean this home grow as aspect of
of any um whether it's legalization or
expanding that um hom grow option to um
for therapeutic cannabis I think it's
very important for Safe products and for
patient access thank you representative
of
Nel I I just feel obligated to say this
um I've been involved in this discussion
for a very long period of time I kind of
take issue with the statement that
cannabis is safer than opioids all the
the opioid data that we have is
basically flawed they basically looked
at deaths without looking at all the
factors involved and the more we've
looked at the factors involved all the
deaths related to opioid use were
actually related to poly Pharmacy and
not single use of opioid when you
basically remove all the extraneous
factors and look at the opioid alone the
opioid overdose death rate is at least
in a prescribed fashion is really not
that high it's when you start combining
things together at the same time we kind
of trivialize the adverse effects of
cannabis that we're seeing increasing
and increasing as we're looking at the
increased use of it and I I'd be honest
I'm really afraid for our youth these
days that they're having increased
access to these substances and what
that's going to mean for the rest of
their lives and I I really seriously
think that we have to remember that when
we make these policies I I'm not a big
advocate of
people growing their own scheduled drugs
at home I I I really do have a problem
in whether it's a schedule two or a
schedule three or a schedule one it's
still a scheduled drug and I understand
the concept of access I think we can
manage that a lot better than allowing
people to grow it on their own at home
so and I I just like the other Bill fine
without adding this to it so I I can't
support the amendment I like the
original
Bill another
discussion representative Seth King
thank you Mr chair originally I wasn't
going to support the original bill at
all I didn't like another data bill um
but the idea of slapping this on there
appeals to me
um this is this if we passed this
amendment this would no longer be a data
bill with a homow attached it would be
in my opinion a hom grow bill with a
datab bill
attached um which I kind of like you
know two can play the game that the
Senate likes to play um and you know the
Congress does this a lot too well they
have these bills that just have so many
different non- gerine things attached to
them and and there have been a lot of
rights that have been won as a result of
that unfortunately there have also been
a lot of rights that have been lost as a
result of that method this is a way we
can use it to gain some rights so that's
why I'm voting for it representative
Palmer thank you um I just have a kind
of procedural question so if we pass
this amendment then when it gets to the
floor the we'd have to vote on the
amendment first anyway right is that um
if we if so if the committee comes out
with a majority position of both
amendments combined it would first be
that combined Amendment if that's
defeated on the floor and if the
minority position is as we've already
amended it then that would be the second
motion would be that second minority
committee
Amendment thank
you other
discussion okay seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call a roll a motion is ought
to pass on 20 24-1 1846 H amendment to
Senate Bill 419 FM representative Lon
yes representative kushman yes clerk
votes no representative kofalt yes
representative mlan yes representative
Seth King yes representative Missour yes
representative Nagel
no representative POF yes
representative Weber
no representative McKay
no representative rung
no representative Canon
yes representative Nutter upam
yes representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant yes yes
representative Murphy no
representative Palmer
yes Representative tez
no and represent McDonald
no 12
to8 mix Amendment passes
okay hey do you have another motion
representative Lon yes sorry um I move a
to pass as amended by by Amendment
1486 and
and 1532
H
sorry okay sorry that's 1532 and
1846 is there a
second representative Lon I mean kushman
sorry oh representative Canon
representative Canon
seconds they're sitting too close
together down
there can't tell whose hand is which
anyway um okay uh any other discussion
on this um
Bill saying none motion is ought to pass
on as amended on Senate bill 14 419
FN representative Lon yes representative
kushman yes CL votes
no representative kofalt yes
representative mlan
yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
no representative poov
yes representative Weber
no representative McKay
no representative rang
no representative Canon yes
representative Nutter upam yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy
no representative Palmer
yes Representative tez
no and representa McDonald
no 12
to8 okay motion
passes um is the minority position ought
to pass as amended by 153 to and if so I
don't know who would want to rewrite
okay and Mr the chair yes when this goes
to the floor in the reports there's two
amendments so is there a report for each
Amendment or is there a report for both
collectively believe they consolidate
don't they representative Weber yes they
they will take the two amendments and
consolidate them into a it will the
amendment will have a different
amendment
number just to make things more
confusing but they'll put them into the
same Amendment as the committee
Amendment and then uh
15 uh 32 will will come out as the
minority
Amendment any any other questions yes um
I I guess just looking as we're going on
I don't know if it would make sense to
miss skip the two that we had the your
main hearings on this morning if we can
tuck them in on the end before people
need to go wonderful but um otherwise I
don't know if it makes sense to go to
554 that not going to be my next
question if we were going to have enough
time to get into get into those um I
have no if there's no objection one we
just go to 554 FN then is that what
you're suggesting representative yes
that's what I'm suggesting because we we
would like a little bit more time for
other amendments but if uh that means
coming back a separate day we can
probably make something work today
and I know a number of people do have to
leave at 3:00 so uh 550 SB 554 FN
representative kushman thank you Mr
chairman I move a to
pass okay and representative Missour yes
okay thank
you uh representative kushman do you
want to speak to your motion yes thank
you um so this bill simply allows the
office of professional lure and
certification and the Department of
Health and Human Services to share
information that they both already have
access to as part of their duties but
cannot communicate to each other so it
just allows oplc and DHHS to data match
information to determine uh Medicaid
certification status of licensed uh
medical
providers okay any other
discussion any other
comments okay I'm seeing none motion is
ought to pass on Senate Bill 554 FN when
the clerk is ready representative Lon
yes representative kushman
yes CL votes yes representative kofalt
yes representative mlan yes representive
Seth King yes representative Missour yes
representative Nagel yes representative
PLO yes representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes representative
rung yes representative Canon yes
representative nut up
yes representative Shapiro yes represent
Merchant yes represent Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes representative
TZ yes and representative McDonald yes
that was
easy um motion passes is there any
objection to
consent 20 to Z I assume y okay I'll go
on consent then uh next up is um Senate
Bill 559
mlan am oh
okay
do
no you already representative mer thank
you Mr chair I'd like to make a motion
to pass Amendment 2024 1831 H okay
motions out to pass on 515 on the
amendment is there a second second
representative Weber second
do you wish to speak to your motion
thank you Mr chair yes I do um basically
the vaccine program is uh what they call
Universal vaccine program what that does
is it allows the providers including
Medicaid to put money into a pot to
allow for the vaccines for children to
be covered so the parents don't have to
worry about the cost of the vaccines
it's really unique not unique to New
Hampshire but New Hampshire is one of
the states that does this it's been a
tremendous asset to many many parents
many many families because they've been
able to get the vaccines for the
children without incurring a financial
burden the bill or the amendment to the
bill does not speak to the Merit of the
vaccine we're not talking about you know
what the merits are of the vaccine we're
talking about coverage Financial
coverage of the vaccine so I to separate
the issue about the vaccine itself as
far as its merits we're not here at
least I think to talk about that part of
it talk about how we can cover the
vaccine for the
families um number two the vaccine
itself is extremely expensive it retails
at about $500 per dose um it's when you
think about that amount of dollars
coming out of a family particular those
on the lower end of the social economic
barrier and talk about the benefit it
has for the children it's a tremendous
asset to them um and number three i'
would say this I heard from the
committee before we talked about trying
to expand it from the normal vaccines to
it we called biological vaccines so what
I heard loud and clear from this
committee was the use of the biological
products or trying to expand it Beyond
RSV was not going to sell well so I went
back
to amend the amendment amend the bill
with this amendment to clearly State all
we're talking about is RSV and RSV only
so at this point in time what I'm
proposing to the committee is that we
narrow things down take the word
biological product out of it so it's not
Broad and make it very narrow to deal
with this one vaccine so I again to mind
people this is a tremendous
benefit to the patient the child to the
family um it does not talk to the Merit
of the vaccine it's not mandating the
vaccine all it's doing is allowing for
financial assistance to those who are
going to get the vaccine so we don't
have to worry about families not having
the ability to pay for
it other discussion representative
Coachman
thank you Mr chairman um thank you for
bringing this amendment um I know that
there is good intention behind this but
uh based on the performance of the
vaccine Association I don't want to give
them any more uh Power at all um
Additionally the use of the word vaccine
to talk about a monoclonal antibody is a
total misnomer they're not vaccines they
don't even contain an antigen they're
more closely um described as IVIG it's
an immunoglobulin
but it's a it's a synthetically made one
instead of one that is uh put into a
solution from pulled BL uh blood serum
so uh I I think that this expands the
scope of the vaccine Association uh
markedly the state should not be in the
business of purchasing
vaccines um it it it gives the state the
incentive to sell vaccines and thereby
Market them and I don't think that's an
appropriate position for the state to be
in I i' rather see the vaccine
Association 126q RSA repealed fully
thank you representative
mlan uh thank you Mr chair and and thank
you for bringing forth the amendment um
I definitely think that uh the the
amendment uh moves things uh in the
right direction and and I'm I'm going to
support the amendment um I'm not going
to support the underlying bill for for
reasons I'll talk about when we get into
that but you know I think that this
amendment
uh takes the bill a long way in a
positive direction and you never know
what's going to happen on the floor in a
very tightly divided house and so I am
way a thousand times more comfortable uh
with this amendment and than I am the
original Bill and and so in that light
I'm going to support it and I would
encourage everybody else to do so as
well representative
bazov thank you Mr chair and thank you
for bringing this amendment I agree that
uh it's uh
it it makes um it makes it better but I
still not comfortable with it and um two
points were made that about excess and
about price so about price I think it's
unfair comparing discounted price That
vaccine Association allegedly can get to
the full listed price uh because as we
know every insurance company or every uh
bulk buyer can negotiate the listed
price down and they do negotiate so uh
if it listed for uh 500 it doesn't mean
that everyone buys it for
500 uh and uh then about access uh uh I
uh I I believe that uh everyone who FS
those
antibodies
already have access to it and uh
coverage as a father of young child I
can testify from my experience my
pediatrician had no problem offering it
to me and even like uh marketing it as a
vaccine uh even though it's antibodies I
lat explained uh that it's not
traditional vaccine but uh they have no
problem offering it to people so uh for
for for
for this reason and agreeing with what
representative kushman said I won't be
supporting this amendment other the
discussion representative Merchant thank
you Mr chair
um question is correct it's not a
traditional vaccine but it is vaccine
it's what to call passive um we have
also rabes vaccine rabes vaccine is also
passive it's antibodies because you
don't have time if you're bitten by a
rabid animal to develop your own
antibodies against the vaccine by the
time you did that you probably wouldn't
be here so it's passive and the same
thing with RSV and some other vaccines
that are known as passive vaccines we
call them vaccines um number two in
regards to rep close off by May the
reason why we go through the universal
program is it allows the state state
doesn't sell it all the state's doing is
acting as a procurement agent to allow
it for distribution the actual use of it
is done by providers and by those
individuals the state's really not
selling anything L is acting as a
conduit and the reason why we do that is
because the Federal Supply schedule
which is only allowed to be accessed is
by governmental AG entities so therefore
if you're private Enterprise you cannot
get the Federal Supply schedule which is
a significant savings to the state to
insurance companies and to pay parents
collectively so when you think of it
that ways it's a passive vaccine it's
still a vaccine number two it's one of
those things allow for the state to
allow them to obtain it to distribute to
the providers at a much reduced price
representative
kushman thank you Mr chairman
respectfully passive vaccine is is
totally antithetical to everything that
I've been taught there's active immunity
that's by natural introduction to an
antigen or there's um there's passive
which is through breastfeeding or um
imunoglobulin but that is not a vaccine
a vaccine has always been defined as
introducing an antigen or or now we have
the MRNA vaccines that create an immune
response after introducing an anen
anagen through a genetic process in the
cell but um the rabies vaccine there's a
rabies vaccine and then there's if you
get bit by an animal and you didn't have
the rabies vaccine there's the rabies
IVIG that's not a vaccine um and and so
even just expanding this you know beyond
vaccines it's it's Mission creep it's
total um you know we're just becoming
salese for for Pharma through the
government of New Hampshire and I think
it's totally
inappropriate representative Missour
thank you can I ask a question so are
children under the Medicaid Program are
they not getting this shot for free
right
now under the under the Medicaid Program
right now that I can't say I'll talk to
someone from the Department my
understanding is Medicaid covers most of
the vaccines probably this one here it's
more in the commercial side I but as far
as I know commercially insured children
this is this shot is covered is covered
for them as well that I don't know I
mean I can can somebody looked into it
and most do
so can we call I don't Department
somebody he to speak on that did you
have information on this or well I was
going to raise the issue of people who
don't have any insurance at all and uh
secondarily I would raise the point that
uh
participating in
the
vaccine um Association reduces the cost
measurably for
everybody so that's just my
comment M Rogers cares to answer the
it thank you Abby Rogers legislative
leaon um just to clarify that the
Medicaid population does receive the
vaccin free of cost or and it is an
immunization technically it is an
immunization uh and that's why we had to
change the uh originally in the Bell we
were trying to change the definition to
include this product but it's not
included under the definition of
vaccination as an immunization or
vaccine like product um the commercially
insured this is this bill is trying to
fix that technical fix so so the payers
uh the carriers can assess and pay for
this product um and it is I think the
testimony of the carrier carriers where
that uh patients can patients parents
can provide can pay out of pocket for
this at the cost of $495 if they needed
to get it but because this um payer
mechanism is is not uh there there's no
definition of biological product or this
new monoclonal in the in the bill so
right now that this would fix that so
commercial insurers would be able to
assess and pay for the
direct any questions for rep M Miss
Rogers representative Weber
do you have any indication that would
give you any idea of the savings uh to
the state through the Medicaid Program
if you don't that's fine I just wondered
uh through through the for RSV for
hospitalizations as a result of not
having the immunization no to to the
cost
of because I assume that the patients
who get
Medicaid do they participate in the
vaccine yes it's well it's yes exactly
so it's free of charge it the state
would purchase the vaccine or or get
into the association at a lower price
and I was wondering if you could tell me
what the price differential was if you
don't know that's fine I can estimate
that it's probably if you were to pay
for it it would be $495 it's about $100
a vaccine cost savings so it's if a
provider order is it it's about
$3995 if he ordered it through the
program versus outside the program so it
would save the state $100 do per
immunization yes per immunization thank
you sure representative Lon and then
representative kosman uh thank you Mr
chairman um I guess this isn't
specifically a question but you may have
some insight in there um looking at this
this is a good example about some of the
way that medicine and everything else
has shifted uh previously a lot of
getting new products out there has been
a lot of reaching out to Providers and
then insurers in order to get things
adopted um there's been a move over the
last decade or so and an even bigger
move um in the last few years to have
things included in state payment because
it's a lot easier it's a pain to deal
with us but it's a lot easier to deal
with us than it is to deal with a whole
bunch of insurers and a whole bunch of
providers so making it so that states
cover the payment makes it easier for
the companies to bring the drugs and it
also makes it easier for them to charge
more money for the drugs so um when you
look at the different business models of
it the business model of bringing
something in especially if it's a high
cost if it's not adopted by the state
and then a lower cost where your
guaranteed sales to every child in the
state is a business model um and that's
not a business model that I'm
comfortable with um I don't like having
the state um be involved in increasing
products even if the marginal use use
cost is lower guaranteeing every every
child in the state or the country or the
world gets it even at a lower price
ensures greater profits for fortical
companies and um the move to profiting
off vaccines as opposed to providing
them them just as something that they
provide with enough to cover the cost
and the losses that happen from it is
one of the things one of the big areas
where I have problems with Pharma while
I don't have problems in a lot of the
do uh representative kushman thank you
Mr chairman um can you tell me isn't it
true that the cost for the vaccines that
are purchased by the vaccine Association
is made up for with increases in the um
in the insurance cost for private
insured
persons I'm sorry I wish Patrick Miller
from the vaccine Association was here to
answer that I don't I don't I could get
back to you certainly with that to
answer to your question um I can tell
you that it is in RSA 126q colon one
assessments means the accessible
entities liability with respect to
Childhood vaccines determined in
accordance with this chapter for purpose
of rate setting and medical loss ratio
calculations all Associated Association
assessments are considered
pharmaceutical or medical benefit costs
and not regulatory costs so they are um
bringing that
into um
the uh administrative costs that then
transfer over to the private sector
Insurance um I'm sorry I can probably
get that to you offline or have Patrick
Miller reach out to you to clarify that
okay that's under the statute that he
works with but thank you thank you sure
other
discussion I'm seeing
none okay um motion is ought to pass on
uh Amendment 20241 1831 H to Senate Bill
559 FN I'll ask the clerk to call the
all representative L
yes Representative kushman
no clerk votes no representative Kofa
this is on the amendment on the
amendment
yes representative mlan
no representative Missour yes un
Amendment representative Nagel
no representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes representative
rung yes representative Canon yes
representative Nutter upam yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy
yes representative Palmer yes
representative tez yes and represent
McDonald
yes 16 to for motion passes or Amendment
passes representative mle did you now
or okay I'll make ahead I'll make a
motion to pass Senate Bill 559 as
amended by Amendment 2024 1831
H okay motion is ought to pass is
amended on uh Senate Bill 559 ofn
is there a second second representative
wber seconds is there any other
discussion seeing none when the clerk is
ready I'll ask him to call I'm sorry
representative Paz off uh uh there are
several reasons why uh I oppose uh uh
this expansion of New Hampshire vaccine
Association uh mandate uh in previous
discussion it it was not quite clear
why we would uh oppose it but at the
very minimum we would want uh this be
efficient we would want it to be
transparent and to be able to follow
current uh statute so with efficient we
briefly uh talk uh about Administration
so what what the cost of administration
overhead you wouldn't be able to find it
because it's hidden in medical expenses
so we can't say um Administration cost
or vaccine waste uh it's always a huge
issue uh with vaccines when they expire
or such uh so we we don't have a dollar
number uh how much uh it costs uh in uh
under procurement uh under this
procurement agent uh uh uh how much
vaccine waste uh course so we can not
say how efficient uh there are issues
with transparency uh uh Zoom meetings uh
video of Zoom meetings are not released
uh uh people are not able people kind of
able to ask them questions but people
are not getting answers and then just uh
recently there was a issue with vaccine
Association change their minutes to
remove a question they didn't like and
with
statues so they without
uh without our authorization vaccine
Association started procuring uh
covid-19 vaccines uh and uh we
authorized vaccine Association to
procure three types of
vaccines uh so first type of vaccine
it's under RSA 12 6 Q column one uh
definition of vaccine so first kind any
preparation of killed
microorganisms it's not a covid vaccine
uh
type second living attenuated organisms
covid vaccine is not living organisms
third type living fully viral viral and
organisms definitely not a covid vaccine
so covid vaccine was not authorized by
this body and yet vaccine Association is
um I don't know why why they doing it
but definitely uh when this question
arised uh they were not comfortable with
it so they removed it from their minute
the question about this so I'm not
comfortable with uh uh giving them even
more
Authority uh because I don't see it as
efficient transparent and following
statutes thank you thank you now
representative McLean and then
representative pmer thank you Mr chair
um you know I'm I'm actually kind of
excited about the potential of um the
Biologicals and I'm excited about the
RSD vaccine um and I I'm kind of this
close to voting for 559 but I can't and
you know and I kind of talk with
representative Merchant a little bit
about this but for me had this bill come
unamended in 2004 it would have passed
out of this committee 20 to nothing it
would have went on the the consent
calendar but you know unfortunately what
happened since then is we did have the
whole covid pandemic happen in the
middle and so my email and my phone is
blowing up with people in in opposition
to this thing and and the reason I think
for that is because prior to the
pandemic there was a fringe group that
was maybe
antivaxx um but the way the whole covid
thing happened trust has totally been
eroded um and so I think for the next
probably 10 years every time we bring
forth the vaccine bill it's going to be
a very very difficult discussion and so
I think one of the things that I
appreciated about this amendment is it
understands that the we're going to go
to reestablishing that trust which we
need to do because we can't be
constantly fighting with the people over
vaccines we got to reestablish that
trust this goes and it takes you know a
nice bite at the Apple and it doesn't go
whole hog and try to eat the whole thing
but I still don't think it's ready and
the reason that I don't think it's ready
is because when I was listening to the
public hearing there were two concerns
for me number one was you know the
efficacy data we're still kind of
waiting on that and then uh Miss Condon
talked a little bit about the liability
concerns and the federal language um is
not yet written to incorporate um the
Biologicals now we heard subsequent
testimony um that that language at the
federal level is being Rewritten um
because but if if if the if the New
Hampshire vaccine Association is going
to be supplying that in advance of
having that immunity that does open us
up to concern so I I really believe that
you know this this we should go on pause
with this bill let the efficacy data
come forward let the federal liability
language be Rewritten in fact and and
not in potential and then we can come
back and as I said representative
Merchant I think this approach is the
approach that we're going to have to
take going forward because I mean the
people who are calling me and emailing
me these are not a bunch of nut bags
okay this these are these these are my
constituency and and they just they've
lost a lot of trust this I think is the
right way but I still think there's some
more work we have to do before we can
bring it forward so that's kind of where
I am with it and I love the amendment
but I can't support the LA
representative
Palmer so I do appreciate the comment
about the constituents my the the
constituents that have emailed me or all
for this bill yeah um and the reason I'm
going to vote for it is 50 to 880,000
kids under five being hospitalized and
the parents have the choice of whether
or not to do this and for the people who
can't afford it I I would want to
support
them other discussion representative
Weber I just wanted to say that I I I'm
speaking for myself and for a great
number of my constituents who also say
that this is uh that are very much Pro
vaccines very much Pro this vaccine and
very much Pro this program so while
there are people reasonable people who
have lost trust who are
questioning they have the ability to
make their own choices about what
they're going to do with it but I think
this is a great program and overall as
the daughter of a polio Survivor I can't
tell you how Prov vaccine I am and how
grateful I am for the progression of
science as things go forward so that's
just a personal
statement representative Merchant thank
you a couple of questions in regards to
the liability issue my understanding is
that the reason why we had the vaccine
liability was because manufacturers were
no longer going to make vaccines in
general because there was such exposure
like liability wise in the government at
that point in time stepped in to create
a pot for them to cover the liability
this truck today is not under that
program hopefully it may come that way
but because the manufacturers releasing
the product today they're responsible
they have the liability now there not
the federal government it's they it's on
them so they're the ones that have to
pick up the liability number two I would
say in regards to the um the issue I
wanted to make a
correction um I I inadvertently confused
myself in my notes um rabus vaccine is a
vaccine rabus immun gabin is immun gabin
it's not passive so I did speak
incorrectly I wanted to CL clarify that
with everybody in the committee um this
is kind of the first RSV vaccine coming
this way as a monoclonal antibody the
other ones are IVIG and some of the
things you talked about before
representment so I wanted to clarify
that with the committee and not have um
I representative Leon um thank you Mr
chairman and I will be brief um I
remember years ago being at an investor
Focus vaccine conference talking about
the ways to make uh more availability um
they included things like adding more
things to the childhood schedule um so
that prepared we would be prepared for a
pandemic and doing things like getting
all all vaccines paid for in the United
States to subsidize the cost both in the
United States and worldwide um I I
appreciate that they brought forward
this RSV um and I appreciate that it's
out there but I'm not in the business of
subsidizing anybody especially not big
Pharma so I'm sorry I but I won't be
able to support
this representative Missour just um you
know big circle in my notes that 106
people were against this online when
when during the hearing so that speaks
volumes to me too so yes I voted for the
amendment um absolutely will not be
voting for this bill okay other disc
discussion seeing no other discussion
let's go to the vote motion is ought to
pass as amended on Senate Bill 559
FN representative Lyon no Representative
kushman no clerk vots no Representative
kofalt
no Representative mlan no representative
Seth King no represent Missour no
Representative pelosa
no representative Weber
yes representative M Kay yes
representative rung yes representative
Canon yes representative Nutter upam yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes this is
representative Murphy
yes representative Palmer yes
representative
tez yes
yes and representative McDonald
no 11 to 10 motion
passes 11 to
n unless we picked up
in okay I assume there'll be a Minority
Report
Report okay um and again we've decided
to continue SP 458 and
sp505 until next week also next week I'd
like to discuss any Senate bills that
have been amended and to see what what
we might want to do with those whether
we want to concur or not um and with
that representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman um there's actually going to be
a lunch from 12:00 to 1 it'll be in the
calendar on Monday on Wednesday when
we're meeting it's talking about uh
biomarkers so it'd be a great thing for
us to attend before we meet for our exec
session and we were going to move that
to 1:30 instead of a one o'clock start
so that we're
bills no the deadline to act is on the
16th um so meeting on the 15th and doing
that but we we but I would like to
discuss the Senate actions on some of
our bills anyway so that would give us
an opportunity to get some additional
business done sorry Lisa repres sorry
representative
Missour no I
understand 1:30
right noon to 1 at St Paul so you can
make it I just wanted to give us time to
walk yes we wanted to let you make it
okay if there's nothing else uh that
that's that concludes our business for